SUBCOMMITTEE ON NASA SERGEANTS
TO PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND ASK THEM TO
REPORT TO THE.
MEETING ROOM NOW I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
.
I GUESS SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS AS WE
GET STARTED HERE.
A FIRST OF ALL WE. WANT.
FOR EVERY BUILT HERE TODAY WE
WILL BE HEARING TO WITNESSES PER
SIDE WITH A TIME LIMIT OF THREE
MINUTES EACH.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL POLICE
STATE ONLY THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION FOR THE RECORD AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE A POSITION
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE OR THAT HER HAVE NO
POSITION BECAUSE OF LIKE THAT AT
THE AGENDA I'M NOT ALLOWING
EXTENSIVE TESTIMONY IF YOU
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE AT. AN AUTHOR VERY
BRIEFLY EXPLAIN IF YOU DID NOT
SUBMIT A LETTER PLEASE ONLY GIVE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION THAT
POSITION.
WE HAVE TO PUBLIC INTO TWO
MICROPHONES SET UP TODAY FOR.
TODAY'S HEARING OUT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BOTH OF THEIR ON
EITHER SIDE OF THE ROOM. OUR
LONGSTANDING POLICY IS THAT
ABSOLUTELY NO SIGNS OR PROPS.
THERE'S NO APPLAUSE OR CHEERING
OR BOOING.
THEN AND SO NOTHING DISPLAYED
DURING YOUR TESTIMONY AND PLEASE
IN FAIRNESS TO BOTH SIDES GIVE
EVERYONE A CHANCE TO SPEAK
LIMIT.
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY.
TO JUST YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL AND THE NAME OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION WHAT CITY YOU COME
FROM SO.
OF FOUR BIT WE HAVE BEFORE BILLS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT TODAY.
THEY ARE ITEMS NUMBER THREE
SAYS S. B. SIX EIGHTY EIGHT BY
MISTER MOORE LOCK WITH.
MINOR AMENDMENTS
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTEEN BY MR MINING. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SCR ONE FIFTEEN
MISTER NEWMAN AND NUMBER EIGHT
SJ ARE TWENTY THREE.
AS HER AS MISS MCGUIRE EXCUSE
ME.
S. B. S. C. R. FOR ONE FIFTEEN
MCGUIRE AND THEN S. J. ARE
TWENTY THREE A MISTER NEWMAN.
SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
OUR OUR OUR HEARING TODAY WITH
OUR FIRST BILL ON SENATOR LABOR
WHICH LIKE TO COME FORWARD
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THINK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
S. B. THREE TWENTY WOULD REQUIRE
ALL ON CAMPUS HELL STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES.
TO PROVIDE MEDICATION FOR EARLY
PREGNANCY TERMINATION FOR THEIR
STUDENTS BY JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY.
ACCORDING TO THE GUTTMACHER
INSTITUTE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
OVER ONE POINTFIVE MILLION
WOMEN IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE
TERMINATED EARLY REGNANCIES
THROUGH THE USE OF MEDICATED
ABORTION.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WOMEN
AGE TWENTY THROUGH TWENTY FOUR
ACCOUNTED FOR THIRTY FOUR
PERCENT OF ABORTIONS THE LARGEST
FOR ANY AGE GROUP. MEDICATION
ABORTION AS A TWO STEP PROCESS
WHERE PATIENT TAKES TWO SETS OF
PILLS OVER THE COURSE OF TWO
DAYS DURING THE FIRST TEN WEEKS
OF PREGNANCY.
ACCORDING TO A UC SAN FRANCISCO
STUDY ABORTION MEDICATION HAS
SERIOUS ADRIFT ADVERSE EFFECTS
AND ONLY ZERO POINT FIVE PERCENT
OF CASES.
WHICH MEANS THAT IT IS SAFER
THAN TYLENOL AND*.
THAT SAME STUDY ALSO FOUND THAT
EVERY MONTH UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
IN NINETEEN STUDENTS AT THE
THIRTY FOUR UC AND CSU CAMPUSES
SEEK MEDICATION ABORTIONS ON
OFFSITE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AT
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
SUCH AS PREGNANCY OPTIONS
COUNSELLING AND CONTRACEPTIVES
ALL CONSIDER THESE SERVICES TO
BE A COMPONENT OF BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A SAFE
PROCEDURE AND IS CLINICALLY
SIMPLER THAN MUCH OF THE CARE
ALREADY OFFERED A COLLEGE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS SUCH AS
DIABETES MANAGEMENT MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. AND DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
MANY COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE
NUMEROUS BARRIERS WHEN SEEKING
TO TERMINATE A PREGNANCY
NCLUDING FINANCIAL LIMITATIONS
LIMITED ACCESS TO RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION AND CONSIDERABLE
DISTANCES TO THE CLOSEST
ABORTION PROVIDER. BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS MEDICATION ABORTION ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
IT'S CRITICAL SINCE MONTH MOST
WOMEN RECEIVE THIS CARE THEY
MIGHT MOST WOMEN MUST RECEIVE
THIS CARE WITHIN TEN WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY. AND MOST WOMEN DON'T
YOU FIND OUT THEY'RE PREGNANT
INTO THEIR FIVE TO SIX WEEKS
INTO THEIR PREGNANCY.
DENYING COMPREHENSIVE AND
ACCESSIBLE REPRODUCTIVE CARE ON
CAMPUS INTERFERES WITH THE WELL
BEING AN ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF
WOMEN AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS DOCTOR DAN GROSSMAN
PROFESSOR AND DIRECTOR OF
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO BRISCOE AND JESSICA.
JESSE A STUDENT AT UC RIVERSIDE
JUST IS GOING TO START.
MY NAME IS JUST YOUR SALAS SIME
A FOURTH YEAR STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE. ASIDE FROM BEING A
STUDENT I ALSO SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
GENERATION ACTION FOR TWO YEARS
ON MY CAMPUS.
AND I HOPE TO CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND TODAY I'M HERE TO
STAND UP FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN UNINTENDED
PREGNANCY.
I WAS JUST BEGINNING MY THIRD
YEAR WHEN I HAD MY ABORTION.
AROUND OCTOBER I STARTED TO FEEL
SICK DECIDED TO GO TO MY STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER.
I DIDN'T THINK I COULD BE
PREGNANT I WAS ON BIRTH CONTROL.
BUT THERE I WAS THE DOCTOR TOLD
ME THAT I WAS PREGNANT.
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I COULD DO I'D
NEW THAT I CAN PROVIDE THE BEST
LIFE FOR MYSELF OR FOR A CHILD
STILL HAD TWO YEARS UNTIL I HAD
TO GRADUALLY AND I WAS. UP
FINANCIALLY UNSTABLE.
I NEEDED AN ABORTION.
THE DOCTOR SET UP AN APPOINTMENT
WITH A DIFFERENT DOCTOR FROM YOU
SEE OUR. LATE DAYS LATER I'M
THAT WITHOUT DOCTOR WHO REFERRED
ME TO THREE DIFFERENT
FACILITIES.
THE FIRST DISABILITY DID NOT
EVEN OFFER ABORTIONS.
THE SECOND ONE DIDN'T.
WITH ABLE TO SCHEDULE ME BUT
NOT UNTIL NOVEMBER.
IF THAT WEREN'T ENOUGH.
TWO WEEKS BEFORE MY APPOINTMENT
THE SECOND FACILITY DENIED MY
INSURANCE CLEANING THAT I DID
NOT HAVE THE UC STUDENT HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN.
FEELING EXTREMELY DISCOURAGED TO
THE ENTIRE ORDEAL SENT ME ON A
DOWNWARD SPIRAL. I DO GO OUT AND
MY GRADES SLIPPED DRAMATICALLY.
AND EVERYDAY WAS EXHAUSTING.
MOST OF MY DAYS ARE SPENT
NAPPING BECAUSE I WAS EXHAUSTED
AND BECAUSE I WANTED TO ESCAPE
THE REALITY OF MY SITUATION.
NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO I THEN
AGAIN CALLED MY STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER AND ASKED ABOUT MY OTHER
OPTIONS.
IT WAS THEN THAT THEY CLARIFIED
THAT I WAS NOT LIMITED TO MY
REFERRALS.
SO FINALLY I WAS ABLE TO
SCHEDULE MY APPOINTMENT WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHICH AGAIN
IS OFF CAMPUS AND I DID NOT HAVE
A CAR.
AND GOT MY PROCEDURE DONE EARLY
DECEMBER.
MY SITUATION COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED IF THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER WAS THERE. AND PROVIDE IN
MEDICATION ABORTIONS FOR
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS
S. B. THREE TWENTY WOULD ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF COULD
HAVE THE CARE THAT I NEEDED WHEN
I NEEDED IT.
MIGRATES AND HEALTH WOULD NOT
HAVE SUFFERED BECAUSE OF IT
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER SHOULD
HAVE HOLISTIC REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AND I HOPE THAT ALL
OF YOU WILL SUPPORT. US SB THREE
TWENTY SO STUDENTS LIKE ME WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THEIR
OPTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE MOVE ON A
MINUTE QUICKEN AND WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO GAS
SECOND CALL ROLE THANK YOU.
WHAT HERE MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BURKE CARILLO. FLORA.
LOW MOAN.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO THURMOND WALDRON.
SO WE DO HAVE QUORUM SO THANK
YOU PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR SECOND WITNESS.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M IN
THANK YOU JESSIE FOR SHARING
YOUR YOUR STORY AND THANK YOU
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS
DOCTOR DANIEL GROSSMAN I'M A
PROFESSOR. IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
OBSTETRICS GYNECOLOGY
REPRODUCTIVE SCIENCES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO RIGHT DIRECTOR
RESEARCH PROGRAM CALLED
ADVANCING YOU STANDARDS AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH OR ANSWER.
MY CLINICAL ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING PROVIDING ABORTION
CARE ARE BASED AT SOCCER BRICKS
IN FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL.
Y. ALSO TRAIN MEDICAL STUDENTS
RESIDENTS FELLOWS IN ADVANCE
PRACTICE CLINICIANS.
I AT THE REQUEST OF THE FIRST
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE TAT HEARD
SB THREE TWENTY SENATE HEALTH.
RESEARCHERS AT ANSWER PERFORM
TWO STUDIES RELATED TO THE BILL
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE COPIES OF OUR
REPORTS AND BOTH OF WHICH HAVE
NOW BEEN PUBLISHED IN PEER
REVIEW JOURNALS.
BEFORE DISCUSS THOSE FINDINGS I
JUST WANNA SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
MEDICATION PORTION ON SENATOR
LEYVA ALREADY DESCRIBED HOW THIS
AND THE MEDICATIONS ARE
PRESCRIBED.
THEY'RE VERY SAFE AND VERY
EFFECTIVE.
AN OVERALL ABOUT THREE PERCENT
OF WOMEN NEED A VACUUM
ASPIRATION OR SURGICAL ABORTION
I'M A VERY VERY SMALL MINORITY.
MEDICATION ABORTION CAN BE
SAFELY OFFERED BY WHO BEAT YOU
ENDS BY FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIANS BY ADVANCED PRACTICE
CLINICIANS INCLUDING YOURS
PRACTITIONERS. PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANTS AND CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES REALLY ANY POSITION OR
CLINICIAN WHO'S BEEN TRAINED TO
PROVIDE THE METHOD.
THE NATIONALS QUE ACADEMIES OF
SCIENCE ENGINEERING AND MEDICINE
ISSUED A REPORT EARLIER THIS
YEAR ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
ABORTION GENERALLY AND
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT MEDICATION
ABORTION AND SPECIFICALLY
HIGHLIGHTED. HOW ADVANCED
PRACTICE CLINICIANS CONCEIVABLY
PROVIDE SERVICE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TALK MORE
ABOUT MEDICATION ABORTION AND
HOW IT'S PROVIDED A FEW
QUESTIONS?
I'M THE FIRST IT HAD LIKE TO
DISCUSS WAS LED BY MY COLLEAGUE
DOCTOR WHO SMOKED POT BE AYE
FROM ANSWER AND AIM TO QUANTIFY
ACCESS TO ABORTION FOR YOU SEE
AND CSU STUDENTS. AND AND ASSESS
HOW FAR A.
THEY HAVE TO TRAVEL TO ACCESS
ABORTION CARE.
BRIEFLY THE RESEARCHERS ESTIMATE
THAT BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO AND FIVE HUNDRED
NINETEEN UC AND CSU STUDENTS
OBTAIN A MEDICATION ABORTION
EACH MONTH. WHICH WORKS OUT TO
BE ABOUT TEN TO FIFTEEN
MEDICATION ABORTIONS PER CAMPUS
PER MONTH AT THIS NUMBER OF
CASES IS SIMILAR TO WHAT OTHER
FAMILY MEDICINE PROVIDERS REPORT
IN THEIR CLINICS AND IT'S
CERTAINLY A SUFFICIENT NUMBER
FOR CLINICIANS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
SKILLS.
IN TERMS OF THE DISTANCE TO THE
NEAREST PROVIDER THE RESEARCHERS
FOUND THAT ACROSS ALL CAMPUSES
THE MEDIAN TIME IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORT. THAT.
PROVIDER THAT I'D STUDENT WOULD
NEED AND TAKE TO GET TOWARD A
CLINIC IS ABOUT THIRTY FOUR
MINUTES EACH WAY GIVEN THE TWO
VISITS THAT WORKS OUT TO BE TWO
HOURS ON PUBLIC TRANSPORT.
THE SECOND STUDY.
WE AIM TO COLLECT INFORMATION
FROM ALL THE UC AND CSU CAMPUSES
AND TO SEE IF THEY HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE MEDICATION
PORTION ON CAMPUS. AND WHAT THEY
WOULD NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
I DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO THROUGH
THAT THAT'S ALL COVERED IN MY
REPORT BUT JUST TO SAY. THAT WE
DID FIND.
THAT.
THAT THIS THE SITES HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED AND
WITH A MODERATE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT SIMILAR TO THE
INVESTMENT THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN.
AND PROMISED TO BUY AND THE
FUNDING CONSORTIUM THAT AT THE
THESE SITES WOULD BE ABLE TO
OFFER MEDICATION ABORTION THEY
WOULD NEED I'M INVEST IN TERMS
OF TRAINING.
IN TERMS OF ULTRASOUND
ARRANGING TWENTY FOUR HOUR CALL
SERVICE ON AND BACK UP FROM
LOCAL A POSITIONS IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS BUT ALL THIS IS VERY
FEASIBLE. ON AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS FUNDING LEVEL FUNDING THAT
HAS BEEN PROMISED TO BE
SUFFICIENT TO PREPARE THE
STUDENT HEALTH CARE CENTERS TO
PROVIDE MEDICATION ABORTION IF
THE BILL WERE TO PASS.
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SO PLEASE AS BEFORE THIS IS FOR
SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION.
ONLY SAN LUIS A MAP CALIFORNIA
LATINAS REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE TO
PROD CO SPONSORED THIS MEASURE.
ENERGY SUPPORT THANK YOU AND
THERE IS A MICROPHONE ON THE
OTHER SIDE AS WELL SO.
HE THE ROBBERS ON THE UC
BERKELEY STUDENT I'M AT THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA
AND WITH STUDENTS UNITED FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AT UC
BERKELEY DESPERATE THIS BILL.
MAKING STEVEN THINK. SPARK OF
SERIOUS IS GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MIRANDA FILLED OUT AT UC
BERKELEY STUDENT AND CO DIRECTOR
OF SCENES NIGHT OF REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS AMANDA ROTH FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I WAS SPARKING I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SIMPLY HAD WITH YES
I'M WITH YOU SEE FF ANSWER
CALIFORNIA LATINAS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE IN A UC SANTA CRUZ
ALUMNI AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SARAH HUTCHINSON WITH ACT FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND TULARE
COUNTY A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
AND WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
AND AS A GOMEZ I'M A LOS ANGELES
CHAPTER LEADER FOR CALIFORNIA
THAT THE MOST REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE MY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I'M PRESLEY MARY.
I'M A STUDENT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI I'M FUSSY WE KEY COULD SULIS
I'M I'M A UC BERKELEY STUDENT MY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HARMONIES ADRIAN DU HAS OF OUR
FOREIGN GIRLS AND TULARE COUNTY
WHERE CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL I
ALSO ATTEND COLLEGE OF SQUARES
VICE AREA AND I'VE HEARD PURGING
JUST PUT THIS BILL.
IF DEVELOPER LARA'S I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MICHELLE GRANT ESTIMATE CSU EAST
BAY IN SUPPORT.
I'M I'M I'M A CIRCUIT YOU I'M IN
A SEC SENATOR AT UC BERKELEY AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M VICTORIA LAST DAM WOULD
SPARK IN THE UC BERKELEY ALUMNI
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS REBECCA WHITEHEAD I'M
A STUDENT AT ORANGE COAST
COLLEGE AND I'M ALSO ONE OF THE
ORGANISM ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
IF YOU.
MY NAME IS AARON GARNER FORDHAM
WITH ACT FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS AND
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS RHIANNON ROSSI
NAME FROM OAKLAND AND I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE MALANA A
STUDENT AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S MELISSA SOME PROGRAM A
STUDENT AT CYPRESS COLLEGE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CALVIN SENDS A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MOLLY JACKSON AND I'M
A STUDENT AT COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AUTUMN BROCK ANIMUS
SOCIAL WORK MAJOR AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CHICO AND I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HOW MANY MASSANA CT I GO TO COST
A ON BEACH AND I SUPPORT THE
SPOKE?
MY NAME IS TRUST THE FILIPINO
GOES NUMB STATE UNIVERSITY AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARY IN REDDING AND
WITH SPARK SF AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M I'M WAY PAST GAVE IT A
STUDENT UC BERKELEY MAYOR DO YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M COURTNEY THROUGH AN ISSUE
NOT UC DAVIS HIRED YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARIA MILLER KNOWS
I'M A STUDENT AT UC MERCED
ENERGY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M TESTIFY FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
SPELL.
MY NAME IS HANA GARCIA I'M A
STUDENT AT CAL STATE LONG BEACH
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS A DIVA CAR AND I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS
BILL.
HOME.
MY NAME'S VIVIAN AND I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT FOR REDWOOD HIGH
SCHOOL ON BY SYLVIA AND I
REVIEWED IT. I'M SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S AMY GRANULOCYTE SF AND
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NEEDS MY LUCIEN NIKOLAIDIS
I'M A STUDENT AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY IMAGE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
ROSE ON OUR MERITS.
AND I GO TO CAL STATE LONG BEACH
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NOT AYE ALLEN BAR I
AM EXTRA PORTRAYER WITH A. S.
UCSB QUICK COMMISSION AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO. SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MA'AM IF I'M A MONDAY WITH THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME THIRTY ON ANY ALL AND
THE STUDENT CRAFTED HILLS
COLLEGE I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FONG AND I'M FROM THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION.
AND OF CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS KATIE ANDREW I AM A
UC BERKELEY ALONG I'M AND
LIFETIME COLLIN AYE ASSOCIATION
MEMBER AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU
SUPPORT BILL.
MY NAME IS ISAAC ENGELBERG FROM
UC BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANNA MEMORANDUM WAS
SPARKED SAN FRANCISCO ENERGY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ISABEL BARBERA I'M
FROM UC BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMY HAMBLIN I'M WITH
SPARK SF I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MARGE PLUMB A GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY I WITH WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE FUNDERS COURT
CONSORTIUM AYE AND WE'VE RAISED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
JUST AND EVEN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE
MY NAME IS COVER THE THING I'M
FROM BERKELEY WITH SPARK SS
ENERGY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GEN FLORI WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
VALERIE CANONISTS A STUDENT
SACRAMENTO AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA'S WAS THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN STIFF
STRYCHNINE BOTH IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
CALAVERAS AND I'M A STUDENT AT
CSU FRESNO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
SURE MEMBERS KATHY MUSBURGER THE
CENTRAL ACCESS HEALTH IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
NIGEL NIXON I'M A STUDENT AT TO
ISSUE A SPAN EXPERTS.
KIMBERLY CHEN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
ORDERED SOME SPORT.
THEY NOW HAVE A MEMBER OF THE
WOMAN'S POLICIES THAT TO A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND A
GRADUATE STUDENT. A GRADUATE OF
UC DAVIS NAY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
ANDREAS AND CAL ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MIGUEL FLORES A GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY AND IT WOULD YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SHERRI GREVEN ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD MAR MONTAIGNE
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS KARLY THE NARROW I'M
A RECENT GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY
AND WAS THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JACKIE GUYS รณ PRESIDENT OF P.
PFLAG PARENTS AND FRIENDS OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KAREN DETACH ALL THAT
SPARK IN THE SAN FRANCISCO STATE
ALUMNI OR DO SUPPORT THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS FRANK HERNANDEZ I
ATTENDED MILLS COLLEGE AND I
URGE YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
UPSTAIRS TO SIR.
MY NAME IS NICK WE REPRESENTING
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MANY OF ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO ONE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
MANY. MY NAME IS REBECCA BUELL
HAGEN AND I AM HERE REPRESENTING
THE MANY CALIFORNIA
COLLEGESTUDENTS WHO FOUND
THEMSELVES AN
UNPLANNED AND SEEMINGLY HOPELESS
PREGNANCIES.
IN FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN I DISCOVERED I WAS
PREGNANT WITH MY SECOND CHILD.
I WILL NEVER FORGET THE DAY I
SAW AT THE GROCERY STORE
BATHROOM.
COMPLETELY ALONE STARING AT THAT
SECOND POSITIVE PREGNANCY TO.
I WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
A FRESHMAN AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND A MOTHER TO
ELEVEN MONTH OLD CHILD.
I HAD JUST LEFT.
PHYSICALLY AND VERBALLY ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP I HAD BEEN ALL OF
MY TEENAGE YEARS.
AND I THOUGHT THAT RAISING TWO
CHILDREN AND EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD
WHILE IN SCHOOL WOULD BE
COMPLETELY IMPOSSIBLE.
SO I SOUGHT A SOLUTION I SOUGHT
OUT A LOCATION.
I QUICKLY LEARNED THAT THERE
WERE EIGHT ABORTION FACILITIES
BETWEEN ME AND MY HOME I'M AND
RUBS THEM WITHIN A TWENTY FIVE
MILE RADIUS CLEARLY
ACCESSIBILITY WAS NOT AN ISSUE.
HOW WITH REALLY NO HOPE IN SIGHT
AND FEELING ALONE SCARED
DESPERATE AND HOPELESS AB YET
MEDICATION ABORTION ON MARCH
THIRTEENTH OF TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN?
IT IS A DAY THAT I WILL NEVER
FORGET.
I WALKED INTO MY FINAL
APPOINTMENT AT A CLINIC IN NORTH
HIGHLANDS AND I AT THIS POINT I
WAS JUST OVER SEVEN WEEKS
PREGNANT. WHEN HE SAT DOWN WITH
THE WOMAN WHO HAD ARE YOU FORTY
SIX ABORTION PALMOS SMALL DIXIE
CUP.
SHE WENT OVER WITH ME AGAIN HOW
THE SERBIAN FLEXIBLE BC IF MORE
NATURAL. AND WE THOUGHT I
SWALLOWED THE PILL IN FRONT OF
HER.
IT WAS SENT ON MY WAY BUT IT WAS
NOT PREPARED FOR WHAT WAS TO
COME NEXT.
BY THE TIME I GOT TO MY CAR WITH
MY BROWN PAPER BAG FULL OF
MEDICATION. I BROKE OUT.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE WHAT JUST
HAPPENED AND I BEGAN TO FEEL
INTENSE SADNESS AND REGRET.
CRISIS IN FEAR HAD FOUGHT MY
MIND FOR THE WEEKS LEADING UP TO
THIS DECISION BUT I COULD NOW
SEE CLEARLY THE EXTENT OF MY
ACTIONS. AND I WANTED SO BADLY
TO TAKE BACK THE LAST TEN
MINUTES OF MY LIFE.
I WAS A MOTHER IN MOURNING
WANTING SO DESPERATELY TO WISH
ALL AWAY.
INSTEAD OF TAKING ME SO PROCESS
ALL.
THE FOLLOWING DAY A DRUG THAT IS
COMMONLY GIVEN TWIN IN IT
ACTIVELY PER TO INDUCE INTENSE
CONTRACTIONS AND TO EXPEL A
FETUS.
I CHANGE MY MIND AND UNDERWENT.
SOME OF THIS BECAUSE SOME OF YOU
MAY CONSIDER THIS CONTROVERSIAL
BUT THE ABORTION WHO OVERSAW
REGIMENT.
THE PROCESS THAT AIMS TO GET
PROGESTERONE BACK INTO A WOMAN'S
BODY TO COUNTERACT THE ARE YOU
FORTY SIX ABORTION PILL I TOOK.
I CARRY DETERRENT MAY NOW ALMOST
FIVE YEAR OLD SON WAS AND STILL
IS PERFECTLY HEALTHY. LAST YEAR
I DID GRADUATE COLLEGE WITH BOTH
OF MY CHILDREN IN ATTENDANCE.
THE I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE WE ARE
STORY ENDED I OFTEN REFLECT ON
THE EMOTIONS I FELT THE DAY
BEGAN MY ABORTION. GRIEF FEAR
HOPELESSNESS GUILT AN INTENSE
SADNESS OR JUST A FEW THAT I CAN
NAME.
LAST MONTH I VISITED THAT VERY
CLEAN TO RETRIEVE MY MEDICAL
RECORDS AND IT WRECKED ME ALL
OVER AGAIN FIVE YEARS LATER.
S. B. EACH WEEK THREE TWENTY
LEAVES ME DEEPLY CONCERNED FOR
STUDENTS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL
ENABLE CAMPUSES AND STUDENTS.
I'M CERTAIN HEALTH CENTERS TO
BECOME PLEASES OF TRAUMATIC JUST
LIKE THAT CLINICS STILL IS FOR
ME. INSTEAD IT IS MY HOPE THAT
CALIFORNIA.
COLLEGES WILL OFFER MORE SUPPORT
RESOURCES ENCOURAGEMENT AND A
PATH THAT DOES NOT LEAVE WOMEN
LIKE ME TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
CHILD'S AND EDUCATION THANK YOU.
BUT HEALTH COMMITTEE.
THE MISSION OF HEALTH CARE IS TO
SAVE LIVES HOWEVER AT THIS BILL.
DOES JUST THE OPPOSITE SPT
TWENTY IS INTENDED TO KILL.
HUMAN LIFE JUST LIKE BECKY SON
UP TO TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
OUR BEHALF OF STUDENTS LIKE
BECKY AND THEIR CHILDREN IN
BILLIONS OF WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN
HURT BY ABORTION WE MUST DO MORE
TO HELP OUR PREGNANT STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS.
ON BEHALF OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS WHOM YOU REPRESENT
HERE AS PART OF THIS COMMITTEE.
INCLUDING THOSE WHO WORK IN
STERN HEALTH CENTERS.
YOU'RE CREATING A BURDENSOME
MANDATE UPON THEM IF THEY HAD
WANTED TO WORK IN AN ABORTION
CLINIC I'M SURE THEY WOULD HAVE
CHOSEN OTHER.
I'M LINE OF BUSINESS IN WHICH TO
SERB THEIR STUDENTS.
THE AUTHOR HAS SAID THAT THIS
ABORTION PILL IS NATURAL AND
SAFE.
HOWEVER THE ABORTION PILL IS.
LOU A LETHAL DRUG
THE ABORTION PILL WAS IN THE
NEWS RECENTLY BECAUSE A
BOYFRIEND GROUND UP THE ABORTION
PILL. AND PUT IT IN THE DRINK
THE TEA OF HIS PREGNANT
GIRLFRIEND WAS PREGNANT WITH
THEIR BABY AT SEVENTEEN WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY. THE BOYFRIEND WAS
SENTENCED TO THREE YEARS IN
PRISON FOR FETAL. HOMICIDE FOR
DELIBERATELY KILLING HIS GIRL
PRINCE BABY WITH THESE CHEMICAL
ABORTION PILLS AND YET. HERE WE
HAVE THIS BILL THAT IS INTENDED
TO.
PROMOTE EVEN GREATER ACCESS
NOTICED THAT THE FIRST PILL IS
PROVIDED WITHIN THE CLINIC
SETTING THE SECOND SET OF PILLS
WHICH CAUSES THE MISCARRIAGE.
IS TAKEN LATER WHO KNOWS WHO
WILL END UP WITH THESE.
PILLS ONCE THEY'RE DISTRIBUTED
ON CAMPUS IN THE UNIVERSITY WILL
BE HELD BE HELD LIABLE OR
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE DEATHS.
I HEARD EARLIER THAT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO BE.
GIVEN TO THIS EFFORT THINK OF
THE SCHOLARSHIPS FOR STUDENTS
LIKE. BECKY AND JUSTIN WHO SPOKE
EARLY EARLIER THINK OF THE
SCHOLARSHIPS THAT COULD BE GIVEN
TO OUR STUDENTS IT'S ON CAMPUSES
THEY. CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS.
THE ITEM OF A BACK SO SUSPEND.
DISCUSSED AND YET WE'VE DONE
OUR RESEARCH WITHIN.
SIX MILES OF ANY.
ON AVERAGE OF ANY YOU SEE CSU
CAMPUS THERE IS ALREADY AN
EXISTING CHEMICAL ABORTION
PROVIDER ACCORDING TO KIM APPIAN
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE UC BERKELEY
UNIVERSITY HEALTH CENTERS. THERE
ARE FOUR FACILITIES WITHIN FOUR
MILES OF UC BERKELEY THAT
ALREADY PROVIDE ABORTION PILLS I
CALLED THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
CLOSEST UC BERKELEY JUST
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON. AND THEY
HAD A CHEMICAL ABORTION
APPOINTMENT WAITING FOR ME THIS
MORNING AND SEVERAL THROUGHOUT
THE WEEK.
ABORTION NUMBERS ARE DROPPING
EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
SUCH A DECLINE FOR THIS SO
CALLED SERVICE WHY WHY WOULD WE
MAKE COMMANDED UPON OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS.
IF THERE'S ANY CREDIBILITY AT
ALL TO THIS ASSERTION OF QUOTE
UNQUOTE LACK OF ACCESS.
WHY PLACE THE MANDATE UPON
UNIVERSITY WHY NOT GO TO THE
ABORTION INDUSTRY DIRECTLY?
THEY HAVE.
THEY'RE SITTING ON TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE AND ACCEPTS
EXCESSIVE EXPENDITURES.
FORCED THEM PUT THE MANDATE ON
THEM TO STAY OPEN LATE ON.
INTO THE EVENING ARE OPEN ON
THE WEEKENDS
OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE INTENDED TO
BE A PLACE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
NOT AN ABORTION CLINIC AND FOR
ALL OF THESE REASONS.
ABORTION HURTS WOMEN THESE THE
ON THE LABEL.
THAT DESCRIBES SOAKING THROUGH
TO FULL SIZE SANITARY PADS PER
HOUR IN PASSING BLOOD CLOTS THE
SIZE OF LIMON AS COMMON
OCCURRENCES DUE TO THESE LETHAL
DRUGS WE ARE TRUE TO VOTE NO
ONE.
SB THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
MY NAME IS MARY LEE SHRIDER I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF RIGHT TO
LIFE OF KERN COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THERESA MARSAN I'M CONCERNED
MOTHER OF A CAL POLY STUDENT.
AND I STRONGLY URGE TO.
TO VOTE NO.
ON SB THREE TWENTY.
HELLO MY NAME SELENA LOPEZ AND
I'M A RECENT GRADUATE OF PRESENT
STATE AND I AM WITH STUDENTS FOR
LIFE AMERICA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NAME'S ASHLEY MCPARTLAND I'M A
NEW MOM AND SO EIGHT AND LET
LEGISLATIVE COORDINATOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PRO LIFE COUNSEL I
RICHARD WHEN OPPOSITION THAT.
THINKS.
I'M SOO ORDER WITH KERN A RIGHT
TO LIFE KERN COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. TO.
JONES READY WITH RIGHT TO LIFE
OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO
LIFE OF TULARE ARTILLERY KINGS
RIGHT TO LIFE ON BEHALF OF OUR
THOUSANDS OF SUPPORTERS
THROUGHOUT THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY MANY OF THEM. CSU FRESNO
ALUMS WE STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN NAME IS A REPRIMAND TO LOW
FRAZIER PASTOR AND OUT WHICH OF
PRIVILEGE COMMUNITY CHURCH
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF FAITH
LEADERS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS MARIA MOLINA I AM A
STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE. AND
PART OF FRESNO STATE STUDENTS
FOR LIFE AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I AM GENERIC TARANTINO FROM
CONCORD I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
CHILDREN'S MINISTRY AT OUR
CHURCH I'M A GRANDMOTHER. A
MOTHER AND A GREAT GRANDMOTHER
AND I URGE YOU STRONGLY TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN LOTHAR I AM
THE PATIENT SERVICES MANAGER OF
SIERRA PREGNANCY AND HEALTH AND
I ASK YOU TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
PASTOR KIM OF SULLIVAN. WESTERN
DISTRICT UNITED PENTECOSTAL
CHURCH I'M AGAINST THIS BILL.
I AM A BUSINESS WISE AND ON
BEHALF OF RIGHT TO LIFE OF SOME
TO CALIFORNIA AND A RECENT
GRADUATE OF FRANCIS STATE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHERYL FICKLE I'M A CONCERNED
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER AND FROM
CHICO AND I ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. GIVE.
HI MY NAME'S MARIE LET THERE BE
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
SACRAMENTO LIFE CENTER AND BOARD
MEMBER OF. CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF PREGNANCY CARE AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW.
MARY MURPHY WALDORF WITH THE A
CS USE.
CHICO STAFF.
AND I STRONGLY.
WHY YOU KNOW VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL WE SEE A LOT OF SUICIDES?
TONY GONZALEZ RECENT GRADUATE
FROM FRESNO STATE WITH RIGHT TO
LIFE OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND
PRESENTS THE STUDENTS FOR LIFE
HIRED YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CHRISTY ANGLADE TO A MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER AND I ALSO HAVE A
CHILD IN THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GEORGE MENDOZA SEMINARIAN OF THE
ROMAN CATHOLIC DIOCESE OF FRESNO
AND THE PRESIDENT FOUNDER AND
CHAIRMAN OF SEMINARIANS FOR A
CULTURE OF LIFE. ON BEHALF OF
OUR MEMBERS AND OUR SUPPORTERS
WE URGE YOU TO STE TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S JEFF ENGLISH PARENT
GRANDPARENT NOT OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
TRICIA LEWIS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AT SIERRA PREGNANCY AND HEALTH
AND BOARD MEMBER AT CALIFORNIA
LIGHTS FOR PREGNANCY CARE URGING
VOTE NO.
I BRED DAY BECAUSE PRESIDENT THE
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE. I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON SB THREE TWENTY.
I'M TANYA FLORES WHAT'S YOUR
PREGNANCY AND HEALTH ON THE
REPRODUCTIVE LOS COORDINATOR I
ASK YOU TO VOTE NO.
I'M SHERRY MILLER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA WITH OUR OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND FAMILY IN LIFE
SUPPORTERS THROUGHOUT THIS GREAT
STATE. WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
THANK YOU.
MY NEMESIS WITH A DATA I'M US
COULD HAPPEN WITH STATE MEMBER
FOR THE FIFTEEN FOR LIFE AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON S. B.
THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS LAURIE PUNCHES AND
FROM SANTA BARBARA AND THE
PARENTS. I ALSO AM A LEADER IN
THE CALIFORNIA INTERCESSORY
PRAYER BECAUSE I SEE VOTE NO I
BEG YOU VOTE NOW.
MY NAME IS THERESA AND I'M WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S STATE STUDENTS
FOR LIFE AND I URGE IF BURDEN
OF.
I'M BARBARA BATTISTINI FROM
SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA AND I
BEG YOU AND ASK YOU TO HUMBLY
VOTE NO. WE STAND FOR LIFE THANK
YOU.
I'M RALPH MERLONI.
MEMBER ST ROSE CATHOLIC PARISH
SWELL SACRAMENTO. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS FANTASY LIFE BILL.
I'M NAOMI DOWN WHITE FROM SANTA
BARBARA CALIFORNIA AND PART OF
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA AND
THERE'S THOUSANDS OF US THAT
FROM THE BOTTOM OF OUR HEARTS
ASK YOU AND BEG YOU TO PLEASE.
SAY NO AND VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I'M RUTH SMITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA DIRECTOR FOR
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA AND
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE.
CONSERVATIVE WOMEN IN THE STATE
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL THAT OPPOSES LIFE.
MY NAME IS JACKIE RODRICK I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND A POST
PARTUM NURSE NAY URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON S. B. THREE TWENTY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GEORGE SMITH I'M FROM
BRAWLEY CALIFORNIA AND FATHER
GRANDPARENT.
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATOR I. POSE
THIS BILL URGE YOU TO VOTE NO.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RUTH PASS REYES HILLARY AND
SENIOR PASTA WITH MY HUSBAND.
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ARLENE CARLA I'M THE
STATE PRESIDENT OF EAGLE FORUM
HAVE A CALIFORNIA THAT REPRESENT
SEVERAL THOUSAND THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE.
AND MY HUSBAND ALSO AS A FORMER
ADMINISTRATOR AT CINEMA STATE
UNIVERSITY WE THINK THIS BILL
WOULD BE VERY HARMFUL TO ANY
UNIVERSITY THAT HAS A FIDUCIARY
TRUST.
TO PROTECT THE CHILDREN THAT
THEIR PARENTS ARE SENDING TO
THEM THANK YOU PLAYS OUT NOW AND
THIS BILL.
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
I AM RELIABLE HARMFUL ARMOR AND
I LED A MAJOR CUCAMONGA
CALIFORNIA A MAN AGAINST HIS.
MY NAME IS THE CHALLENGE OF
COVERT AND I'M DENTAL ASSISTANT
AND I'M AGAINST THIS BILL.
S. B. THIRTY TWO ZERO.
LIKING IS FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA
CALIFORNIA AND I AM AGAINST THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SWAN TO HEAD ON KNOW
AND I'M FROM FUNDS IN A
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO. MY NAME IS.
LEXIE KAREN AND I AM. AYE
OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS GRACE WALLACE AND I'M
FROM SANTA BARBARA KNOCK
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME'S JAMAR QUARRELS FROM
RIALTO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. KID
KAREN CLEANER SACRAMENTO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE CHEMICAL
ABORTION PILL.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS I MACAU IN OUR
FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CYNTHIA FINK FROM
REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B.. THREE
TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS JORDAN SANTA ANA
FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARGARET TO TAR
AND I'M FROM FONTANA CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPILL.
HI MY NAME IS SAMANTHA NEW
YEAR'S I'M FROM SAM IF YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS RYAN SIMPKINS I'M
HERE FROM ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
MURDERING OF INNOCENT CHILDREN.
KALRA MOLE FOR AYE SHAY DARING.
PRICES.
MY NAME IS MASON LOTHAR I LIVE
IN LINCOLN CALIFORNIAN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROSE HIV.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH DUNCAN AND I
SERVE THE LORD. WITH A GROUP
CALLED PROJECT TRUTH WE SERVE ON
COLLEGES CAMPUSES WE SERVER FOR
A PLANT PARENTHOOD'S.
I'VE SEEN WOMEN IN TEARS
WHO'VE HAD ABORTIONS JUST YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATIONS AND I AM
SAYING I AM PLEADING WITH YOU
ALL. TO VOTE NO ON IT S. B.
THREE TWO ZERO.
MAY GOD AWAKING YOU.
GEN NOW MARTINEZ I AM FROM RAIL
TO CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHANE CALDERA I'M A
BORN AGAIN CHRISTIAN FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
TAKE.
HI MY NAME IS SARAH ANDERSON AM
AGAINST MURDERING CHILDREN.
AND IN HIS MERCEDES LOW FARE MY
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT AND I
POSSESS BUT.
HI AM EMILY ANDERSON AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS HALEY BARBOUR
SIGN I'M A STUDENT FROM BIOLA
UNIVERSITY AND I OPPOSE THIS
LAW.
MY NAME IS SERIOUS LAWSUIT ON
FROM THE COUNCIL NAY LAKE
ELSINORE CALIFORNIA SHOW WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH KEELING FROM
COLLUDED CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JASON FRANCISCO FROM
FONTANA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY KENNEDY
WORDS PROUD MOTHER OF TWO SIGNS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO GET.
MINISTRY ANNIKA GARCIA I'M FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BRENDA BEEN ON FROM
SACRAMENTO ON A MOTHER AND A
GRANDMOTHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SIMPLISTIC I WANT YOU KNOW.
NO ASSUME DIRE QUOTE OR
ABORTION.
ROBIN COULTER FROM ALCOHOL
CALIFORNIA.
CLOSEST.
HI MY NAME IS BIANCA SEE ARE AND
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S CAROLYN WEEKS I'M A
MOM OF TWO BEAUTIFUL BOYS FROM
LODI CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY CHEN UPON
TEMPLE CITY CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE VOTE NO FOR THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ARE REBEKAH MAURY 'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
S. B. THREE TWENTY.
I MENDOZA IT'S ESTHER HONG.
I OUTPOSTS THAT THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA DURAN I
LIVE RANCHO CUCAMONGA CALIFORNIA
AND THEY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS JULIA LITTLE I'M
PHONE THE SAUCE COUNTY FUNNIER.
PRIESTS รณ BALL KNOWN AMONG THE
ESPYS BROUGH TWENTY THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S JACQUELINE NAMES STONE
AFFRONT ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA.
I'M AGAINST THE. ISPS RETURNED.
HELLO MY NAME IS A CREEL ASSAY
BOONS TO.
I'M A VICTIM OF ABORTION.
AND I'M A MINNESOTA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY
THINK.
HI MY NAME IS SHE HOME WHILE AND
FROM FOLSOM CALIFORNIA. UP I HAD
THE ABORTION WHEN I WASN'T THE
WITH.
HELLO MY NAME IS TIMOTHY WEAVER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
HELLO MY NAME IS PROGRAM SHUT
FROM BANDAI ON A CALIFORNIA I
SAY NOT THE OF THIS BILL.
HI I'M GRACE I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M IRIS MENDOZA FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND I STRONGLY
POST IS BUILT INTO.
HI MY NAME IS AT THEY PROMOTE.
AND STUDY HALLS.
MY NAME IS EVELYN COLONIAL FROM
MARINO VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LOVE PASSED A PRETTY
HILLARY FROM SHALLOW TABERNACLE
CHURCH IN RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M PASSED EMERY A FAITH FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CINDY TAN I'M COME
FROM.
ALGO CALIFORNIA.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S TREATMENT CAN
AND I'M A YOUTH PASTOR FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS A LOAD PARA COME
FROM.
YOU'LL BUT I YOU KNOW CD YOLO
COUNTY SO AND STRONGLY OPPOSED
THE BILL. IF.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSICA GARCIA
AND I AM ONLY YOUTH PASTOR AND
SHALLOW OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LAME FRIENDS
SEWELL I'M FROM.
FREMONT HIGH FLOWN YA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M CYNTHIA SHANKLIN FROM
LASSEN CITY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THING HERE.
MY NAME IS CHRIS AND I'M AYE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES.
HI MY NAME IS CRISTINA LOPEZ ON
FOR MUCH OF THE MANGA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS A CHAO SHE I'M FROM
FREMONT AS JOHNNY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
GENE SHAY I'M FROM CERRITOS
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELISA AT YOUR
BECAUSE. I'M.
UC DAVIS ALUMNI AND.
HEALTH MAJOR. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
IT'S
VERY.
MELISSA SANDRA YAN I'M COMING
FROM.
DIAMOND BAR CALIFORNIA I HAVE
I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME CECILIA CHAVIS I'M
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I HAVE
FIVE CHILDREN MYSELF.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI UM MY NAME IS GRACE WORKING
FOR ICSE METAL CENTER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPAM. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS REACHING GAY
I'M FUMBLING HIGHS CALIFORNIA
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL S.
B. THREE. TWENTY.
MY NAME'S JENNY I FARM.
LOS ANGELES I KNOW.
ICE BE YEAH THREE TWO ZERO.
MY NAME IS HANNAH MA I COME FROM
CALIFORNIA.
I OPPOSE THE FEES THEY.
LAUREL.
MY NAME IS JOY TOLL UP FROM THAT
KIND OF FUNNY HOW GLAD. I IN A
STRONG GLOVE OPPOSED THAT SB
THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS STEVEN LIU FROM OR
ANY HIM ORANGE CO.
COUNTY.
AIR EIGHT.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. THREE
TWENTY.
THANK YOU.
HI I MY NAME'S  AND NEARLY
AYE FORM PUBLICITY CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY.
UP PULL S. B. THREE TURNED BEET.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOYCE LOW I'M COMING
FROM BELLFLOWER CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY
BECAUSE I DO CONSIDER THAT AS
SOME.
MY NAME IS MARY CHIU I AM FROM
CALIFORNIA ONE THAT'S.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. THREE TO
ALL.
MY NAME IS LEE WILL AWAY FROM
OF.
L. A..
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SPC HUNDRED
PLENTY.
MONIES TO ME SURE I'M OPPOSES
SIS'S EARNED.
A SPEECH YOU.
SLIP ON HERE.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER LIEU I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S JULIE OUT LONG I'M
FROM. TUSTIN CALIFORNIA I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS PITCHER FOR I AM
WRONG I DON'T EIGHT I OPPOSE S.
B..
SORRY TO.
DEAL.
HI MY NAME IS MATT I'M LEON I'M.
I. I FROM A SIRI TOTE EVEN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY.
A POSTER AS I SPEAK THREE TWENTY
THANK YOU.
AND THEN THE HOT ONLY DO I
AFROMAN AND THEIR EIGHT.
BOB PULLS.
AND IF.
TO BE SO.
BUT THAT S. B. US AS THREE TOOL
AT THEIR.
MY NAME A SOMEONE EACH OUNCE
EYEBROW MOROSE ME CALIFORNIA ICE
BLOCKS BOTH THE CITY OF OF THREE
PLAN P. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STILL FAIRLY I'M FROM
UC DAVIS I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BICU.
MY NAME IS TO LEAVE YOUR SON NOT
PAY LEAVING FEDEX.
AND THERE I HAVE TEN CHILDREN
SEVENTEEN GRANDCHILDREN I AM PRO
LIFE. I AM OFF BECAUSE I.
WHO LAW THREE SB THIRTY HONDA
TONY LIKE IF YOU?
I MARISKA EVAN WHEN I'M FROM
WEST SACRAMENTO ALMOST UNOPPOSED
IN DESPAIR THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME HE SAID EUGENIUSZ
TEUTONIC I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SB THREE TWENTY.
AND MY NAME IS A HOLIDAY OUT
YOUR OWN I AM COMING FROM LOS
ANGELES I STRONGLY. OPPOSE S. B.
THREE TWO ZERO THANKS.
MY NAME IS OUT A LEON LA I UP
WAS TO BE A.
BUT STEVEN B. THREE TORRENT.
IF.
OKAY I'M WHALEY WONG'S I'M FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. THREE TWENTY.
PICTURE.
MY NAME IS BRENDA WOULD I'M FROM
RIVERSIDE AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
VOTE NO ON S. B. THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS ALICE YEAH I'M COMING
FROM LONG LA COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LORRAINE A MY AND I'M
FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE. SB THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS PEGGY CHAREN I COME
FROM A CALIFORNIA OF LOS ANGELES
AND I IT. TORY.
OPPOSE THE SP THREE TENDED THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CAMMY RE BE I AM
ADOPTED AND VERY PRO LIFE SO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS PAMELA WHOLE รณ
AND FROM IRVINE CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL BARNES AND
FROM EL DORADO HILLS.
IN PROVERBS IT SAYS THERE'S A
WAY THAT.
MY NAME IS TO EACH CHAU AND
CONFERENCE DIAPERS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPEAR.
DAVID HALTON FROM IRVINE KIND OF
WANNA I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S.
B. THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS AGNES AND I'VE
FOUGHT I'M FARM FAN YAGO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
S. B. THREE TWENTY.
I NAMES FRED WOO FROM WEST
COVINA CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL SP
THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PAUL SHARE I'M PHAM
ACADIA.
DAVIS.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL S.
B. THREE TIMES.
MONIES PEARL.
I COME FROM CHINO HILLS
CALIFORNIA AS FROM OPPOSED. A
SPEECH THREE TWENTY.
I'M SERA O. AYE AYE FROM DAVIS
THE T..
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BEER.
MY NAME IS WENDY LEE I'M FOR LOS
ANGELES I STRONGLY OPPOSE SAY
SPEAK THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
HELLO ALL I'M I'M CREWS FROM THE
OF HOW MY COUNTY FROM THE I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED SO THIS POLICY
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS VALUABLE.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH TOOL I COME
FROM KIND FOR THE YEAH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SB THREE
TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS THE GIMBAL I FOR
ALL MORE A ARE AMONG TO
CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY UP THE ICE OF
SUPPORT OF THE S.
THREE TWENTY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TERRY YELLOW PHONE
THEM ON BY LOS ANGELES.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A SPEED THREE
HUNDRED THANKS.
YEAH THIS IS MY LA LAW. GO HEAD
TO HEAD.
YEAH AND THIS IS A SHAUN CHEN
I'M A PASTOR WHEN I WAS COVINA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LIZ SMITH AB ALONG
I'M FROM HAYWARD CALIFORNIA I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE. S. B. THREE
PLENTY.
NO TO ABORT.
MY NAME CITY HOME NEW FORUM
SACRAMENTAL.
FONG I STRONGLYAB POST DISPUTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARY
BALLOT NATIONAL AND I'M FROM
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS S. B. THREE TWENTY I
THINK YOU.
MY NAME IS YOU WASH AND I'M FROM
EL DORADO HILLS CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOM OF THREE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS IMELDA'S ANITA FROM I
HE AWARD CALIFORNIA. AND NOW I
AM HERE TO POST S. B. THREE
TWENTY.
NO MCNICHOL LOW GROWTH.
I'M AN OSTEOPATH THE SOKAYA
TRISTAN REPRESENTS SEVERAL
CHURCH GROUPS AND SOME PRAYER
GROUPS AND PUBLIC WORDS
MINISTRIES.
THIS IS RATHER A CONVENIENT
EXTENSION.
HI MY NAME IS S. THIRD. ALL I AM
FROM THE.
SACRAMENTO. I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
A. B. S. B. FRITO ZERO.
A NO OPPOSED NO UP.
HELLO MY NAME IS SESSION DAVIS
SOME FROM OUT GROWTH CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. S.
B. THREE TRAINING THAN PEOPLE
THINK.
MY NAME IS NANCY MOM FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY AM A
SCIENTIST BY TRAINING THINKS
YOU.
HI I'M ROBERT PIMENTA I'VE
REALLY VALUE LIFE.
I AM A FATHER OF THREE CHILDREN
GRANDFATHER OF SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN. AND ALREADY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE OF THEM AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IF.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICK
TRAVERS ON FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA FATHER FIVE BOYS.
HOUSE A FATHER AT FIFTEEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
S. B. THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATE THEN DAVIS
FROM ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA FATHER
THREE BOYS WHO STRONGLY OPPOSE
S. B. THREE TWO ZERO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFFREY PERRINE I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY NAME'S MARCELLA COLLINS
I'M AN EDUCATOR FOR SOMEBODY. I
DROVE SEVEN HOURS ALL THE WAY TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BUT IT IS MARKETS CENTER SOME
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA NAY
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. THREE
TWENTY.
MY NAME IS NICOLAS COLLINS I'M
FROM VICTORVILLE CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO AN EDUCATOR AND I ALSO
OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS LA PSALM I'M A FROM A
FREE FREMONT A CALIFORNIA. I'M
IS. OPPOSE SIR S. B. STREET
TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID MADLY I
DROVE ALL THE WAY FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY.
BANKING.
MY NAME IS JAY MEL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE FILLED THREE
TWENTY.
MY NAME IS CHRIS STEM FROM
CLASSICAL COUNTY I M. SPORT LIFE
FOR ALSO A OPPOSE SB THREE
TWENTY
MY NAME IS RANDY THOMASON
PRESIDENT OF CAMPING FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
WE OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY
BECAUSE IT LACKS MEDICAL STE.
THEY AMY WEST I'M AN EDUCATOR
AND SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AYE
OPPOSED OUR S. B. THREE TWENTY
AND THESE ARE MY.
DO GROW AND I LIVE IN NEVADA
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
S. B. THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AARON EASTMAN FROM
PLACERVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS MIGUEL RODRIGUEZ SOME
FROM SANDRA FELL.
MY MOM WAS AN UNWED MOTHER WHO
SAID NO TO A BOARDING ME.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. THREE
TWENTY.
HELLO I'M SCARED KILEY AND FROM
PLACERVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THINK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ARE NOTABLE SYAM FROM
LOBATO. ARE AYE STERN DIAZ
POSTED THERE S. B. TREE TO ANY.
HI MY NAME IS PART POINT A CHIP
PRINT FROM VALENCIA CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY TOOK HIS ON
I COME FROM A MAIN A FAMILY OF
TEN CHILDREN I MYSELF HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN AND I AM PASSIONATELY
AGAINST SB THREE TWENTY.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN CAL I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL WITH RESPECT TO SENATOR
LEYVA APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK
BUT RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF
OUR THOUSANDS OF CONSTITUENTS WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND IT'S GOING TO GO BACK AND
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO POSTED HIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MENDENHALL AND RUNNING TO BEACH
CALIFORNIA. FORMALLY A HEALTH
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SO SPEAK THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S NAOMI AT US I LIVE
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY
AND I THANK YOU FOR.
LISTENING TO THE VOICES.
MY NAME IS EVER SO LISA COME
FROM ONTARIO CALIFORNIA I WAS
NOT BLESSED ENOUGH TO HAVE
CHILDREN I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS SOPHIA I'M FROM
BAY AREA. THANKS FOR YOUR HOW
WORKING BUT I'M HERE TO OPPOSE
THAT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JUDGE IN THIS OP.
TAKE AWAY BUT OF CHILDREN FROM
THIS LAND.
I AM A GAY THIS LAW.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DIE YOUNG CHEN I'M
FOND OF AYE CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
MEDICAL PHYSICIST AND OPPOSE HIS
BILL.
EVERY TONGUE SHALL CONFESS THAT
YOU.
12-1 CHEN CHROME.
Y. CORDIFOLIA I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HEY I'M EVAN I'M AGAINST THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SHANA BOOMER SHINE
FROM DANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JAKE GOODBYE FROM
TRACY CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THINKING.
HI I'M CHRISTIE BENOWITZ I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO AND I'M AGAINST
THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS REMA HATE THREE
AND AYE A STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
THREE TWENTY I'M FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA THING HERE.
FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA I OPPOSE
S. B. THREE TWENTY.
GRAYSON RAIL TO TARA RANCHO
CUCAMONGA I OPPOSE SB THREE
TWENTY.
EVELYN IGNACIO FROM WEST COVINA
CALIFORNIA I HUMBLY IMPLORE YOU
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
A FLORA THROUGHOUT I AM FOR THE
CBO SOUND CAPISTRANO AND STRUCK
A STRONG OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS LISA SANCHEZ AND I
AM FOR MEDI HE CALIFORNIA AND I
DO OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIEL AIR AND I'M A
STUDENT IN NAPA CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANNA AARON NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL COORDINATOR
FOR STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF AMERICA
REPRESENTING NINETY STUDENT
GROUPS IN THE STATE. AND I URGE
YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BUT THAT IS ABOUT IT YEAH LEADER
OF THE RESPECT LIVE MINISTRY AT
THAT THE IT OUT AND ALSO COULD
BE MADE OUT OF THAT YOUTH GROUP.
MOTHER FOR.
I BUSINESS OWNER AND TAXPAYERS
NO TO S. B. THREE TWENTY MANY
FRESNO STATE STUDENT AND
MEMBER OF FOR HAS NO STATE
STUDENTS FOR LIFE AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON SB THREE TWENTY.
HI MY NAME IS LAURA RODRIGUEZ
I'M A STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE
ENERGY TO VOTE NO ON S. B. THREE
TWENTY.
MARIA AND A MEMBER OF STUDENTS
FOR LIFE OF AMERICA AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BERNADETTE TCM THE
PRESIDENT OF FRESNO STATE
STUDENTS FOR LIFE AND A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL.
I'M DEBBIE PRITCHARD FROM OUR
MONA MOTHER OF AN UNPLANNED
PREGNANCY WILL AT FRESNO STATE
PLEASE OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY.
I AM TUNDRA MAUREEN I AM
ASSOCIATE PASTOR AND I CHAPLAIN.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LEADER REALTORS HIGH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PAUL YOU TO FROM RANCHO
CUCAMONGA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS LANCE BRADFORD I'M A
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO I'M I'M ALEXANDER KOCE I'M
A MEMBER OF SAINT EUGENE'S IN
SANTA ROSA TIME. AND I'M A
FORMER GRADUATE OF CITY COLLEGE
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
PASTOR DANIEL NINE YEARS FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PASTOR MIGUEL NUNEZ FROM RANCHO
CUCAMONGA AND I PUT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROBERT BYRD IMAGINE
YOUR COLLEGE STUDENT AND SEVEN
CISCO ALSO WITH PRO LIFE YOU.
PRO LIFE SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON THE SPELL SUPPORT TITLE
NINE RIGHTS.
MY NAME IS ROSEMARY MAULANA
PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR AND BOIL
CALIFORNIA AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARIA VANDENBERG I'M
FROM IRVINE CALIFORNIA HAS
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IF YOU.
THE BLESSING MANY MISS EUGENIA
SANTANA AT NUMBER PASSED HER
SHUT RECOVERED. TO DATE ME AND
MY HUSBAND DONALD SANTANA WE ASK
YOU TO PLEASE.
A POST THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S LYNDON ENOUGH OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND REGISTERED
NURSE GRETCHEN IF YOU SEE SAN
FRANCISCO I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON S. B. THREE TWENTY THANK YOU.
I'M STEVE PATENT RESPECT LIFE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CATHOLIC
DIOCESE OF SACRAMENTO
REPRESENTING A BISHOP PROMISED
SOTO.
ASK YOU TO EITHER VOTE NO OR TO
ABSTAIN ON THIS.
ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S MARY CERI AND I URGE
YOU PLEASE SPOKE NO ON THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S MARY CRAWLING I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAMING IN THE CECILIA HIM AND
INFLOWS SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
PLEASE BORE NO IN THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ROSY TIE THIS I'M
WITH.
SHALL TABERNACLE CHURCH FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S SHANE GRAY FROM
RANCHO CUCAMONGA MY PASTOR IN A
CHAPLAIN AND PHILANTHROPISTS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MORRELL BOWMAN POLLOCK PINES
CALIFORNIA. DIRECTOR PRE
CALIFORNIA AND THE GLOBAL
WOMEN'S MINISTRY DIRECTOR FOR
THE UNITED STATES NATIONAL PER
COUNSEL PLEASE NO ONE SP THREE
TWO ZERO.
MY NAME IS OLGA HERMAN I'M IN
SACRAMENTO I'M DIRECTOR FOR LIFE
WITH THE US NATIONAL PRAYER
COUNSEL AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON S. B. THREE TWENTY IN
JESUS NAME.
MY NAME IS AND I TOOK AS I AM
FROM SACRAMENTO AYE YOU APPLAUSE
THIS VEAL S. B.. THIRTY ONE.
NONETHELESS A CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE AND YOU
OFFER LETTER IN OPPOSITION.
SUPPOSE.
MY NAME IS LYDIA TAP I OPPOSE
THIS.
BM.
FROM CITRUS HEIGHTS SACRAMENTO.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHARLES TAB.
I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO I AM
OPPOSED THESE BE TAKEN SO MUCH
BUT.
MY NAME'S CHARMAINE DENNIS I'M A
PRO LIFER FROM MODESTO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WE REPRESENT.
.
PRO LIFE SAN JOAQUIN AND.
WE HAVE THREE OR FORTY SEVEN
OTHER PETITIONERS WHO WHO'S A
SIGNED A PETITION TO TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS OLYMPIA PHANTASM
FOR LIFE SO I OPPOSE IT.
I'M OUTNUMBERED UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ALONG THIS.
PRENATAL MURDER OPPONENTS
PLEASE KEEP PRAYING ON PRENATAL
MURDER
.
RALPH.
BILL CALIFORNIA.
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
ANYONE ELSE.
MY NAME IS KEVIN CANTY FROM
ROSEVILLE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS SEAN COONEY OPPOSED
TO SPELL.
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE AS IT SEEMED NO ONE TOLD
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE COMMENTS WE ARE.
AS WELL.
THANK YOU I.
OF COURSE IT WAS A LOT OF.
TESTIMONY IN THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND I.
I WANT TO LOOK UP YOU KNOW WHAT
IS THIS ARE YOU FOUR EIGHTY SIX
SO WHAT THE* DO.
AND THE IT'S WHEN I GOOGLE IT
YOU KNOW YOU JUST GO ONLINE AND
LOOK GOOD FOR DIFFERENT SO TRY
TO FIND A A FAIRLY. ACCURATE.
WEBSITE AND IT SAYS THAT IT'S A
CHEMICAL.
THE BLOCK THE ACTION OF THE
HORMONE PROGESTERONE.
SO FOR JUST FROM IS NEEDED TO
CONTINUE PREGNANCY.
NORMAL IMPLANTATION.
A OF THE PLACENTAL.
TO VOTE LINING OF THE UTERUS.
BUT WHAT FLOOR ARE YOU FOUR
EIGHTY SIX THOSE. CAUSES LOW
LYING TO DIE AND SEPARATE FROM
THE UNIT AND BALL.
AND WHEN THIS HAPPENS THE BLOOD
SUPPLY THE GHOSTS OF THE BABY.
THE CARRIES THE NUTRIENTS IN THE
OXYGEN IS CUT OFF SO.
EVENTUALLY THE. PLACENTA FALLS
AWAY IN THE BABY HUNT. AND THEN
THEIR. OWN.
THAT'S WHAT KILLS THE BABY SO.
I THOUGHT OKAY SO I UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT WORKS IN IN ON THIS ARE
LOT OF ISSUES WITH IT. COME BOTH
MEDICALLY.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY JUST IN
ONLY TAKING ADVIL BECAUSE THERE
IS.
SIDE EFFECTS.
WHEN I LOOKED YOU KNOW IT'S IS
BASICALLY EVERYONE'S GONNA HAVE
CRAMPING TO SOME EXTENT THOSE
BLEEDING.
PAIN NAUSEA DIARRHEA STOMACH
PAIN ALL THESE THINGS BUT YOU
KNOW IS A MOM AND I THINK ABOUT
YOU KNOW THE LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE
OUT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THEIR
HOME.
THEY MAY HAVE AN ALLERGIC
REACTION EVEN THEY MAY HAVE AN
EVEN ONLY SINGS ARE SLIM. YOU
KNOW AND IN SOME CASES RARE.
THERE IS AN INFECTION THAT COULD
CALM AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO.
NO MY WORRY IS.
YOU KNOW LOOKING AT YOUNG PEOPLE
FOR THE FIRST TIME WHEN WHAT
THEY KNOW.
YOU KNOW AT WHAT LEVEL THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND SOMETHING THAT
THEY NEED TO GO BACK WHAT TO SEE
ITS POSITION.
SO THERE THERE'S CONCERNS
MEDICALLY IN THAT REGARD HOME
BUT I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
FOR.
EITHER SIDE WHO WERE WITNESSES
OR ANYONE WHO CAN ANSWER.
.
JUST BECAUSE I READ THE BILL SO
WASN'T SURE.
IT DIDN'T EXPLICITLY SAY IN THE
BILL SOME OF THIS.
.
PART OF IT IS EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
WORKING IN IN THESE HEALTH
CLINICS IN THOSE THINGS SCHOOLS.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM IF THEY
REFUSE TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE OF
THEIR CONSCIENCE AS THERE A
EXCLUSION?
FOR CONSCIENCE OBJECTION.
DID THE FOLKS WHO WORK IN THE
HEALTH CARE CENTER DON'T HAVE TO
WORK IF THEY DON'T WANT TO.
WELL THEN THAT THE ANSWER IS IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO ADMINISTER IT
THEY WOULD NOT BE HIRED TO
ADMINISTER A BECAUSE HOUSE BE
ADMINISTERED BY AN RN.
OKAY.
AND I KNOW THEY HAVE TO HAVE
TRAINING IN THERE'S NO THERE'S A
WHOLE SERIES OF FOLKS THAT CAN
GET THAT TRAINING.
SO OKAY.
.
AND THE OTHER THING WAS.
REGARDING LIABILITY.
I THINK IT WAS BROUGHT UP. IN
THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY.
WHAT IF SOME OF THE SIDE EFFECTS
HAPPEN IN THERE IS AN INJURY?
IS THE SCHOOL LIABLE OR DOES THE
BILL CONTAINS.
AN EXEMPTION NORA.
BUT THE SCHOOL IS NO MORE LIABLE
FOR THIS PROCEDURE THAN THEY ARE
FOR ANY OTHER PROCEDUREAT THAT
A STUDENT MIGHT OBTAIN AT THE
HEALTH CENTER.
.
SO WOULD THAT DOES AND I WOULD
ASSUME THEN THE SAME THING WILL
GO FOR THE HEALTH CENTERS THAT
THEY HAVE.
A.
TRANSFER AGREEMENT WITH A LOCAL
HOSPITAL
FOR ANY OF THAT THESE
COMPLICATIONS ARE ANY OTHER. I
JUST I MASSIVE ASCENDANCY IN THE
BILL EXPERT.
DR GROSSMAN.
AND JUST TO SAY THAT THERE IS NO
MEDICAL REASON WHY THEY WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE A TRANSFER
AGREEMENT LIKE A WRITTEN
TRANSFER AGREEMENT IN FACT. THE
RECENT REPORT FROM THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE ENGINEERING
IN MEDICINE SAID SUCH
WRITTEN AGREEMENTS ARE NOT
MEDICALLY NECESSARY IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHERE TO SEND.
PATIENTS WHO HAVE A RARE
COMPLICATION SO THEY CAN GET
TREATMENT BUT THAT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE THROUGH A WRITTEN
AGREEMENT.
OKAY BUT THE SINCE IT'S A HEALTH
CENTER.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY DO HAVE
SOME.
AGREEMENTS WITH THE LOCAL
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOM FOR
ANYTHING BROKEN LEG OR ANYTHING
ELSE WHEN WE WOULD HOPE SO TOO.
OKAY LET'S JUST ONE OF THIS IS
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I I.
READ THE BILL.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST COM.
THERE IS SOME LANGUAGE THAT SAYS
THAT GENERALFUND MONIES OR
STUDENT FEES.
FOR MEDICATION FOR SOMEBODY IN
THIS OP THAT THAT WOULDN'T BE
USED BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO.
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO COULD SOME
STUDENT FEES GO TOWARDS THAT?
THAT THAT IS NOT WHAT WE WANT TO
HAVE HAPPEN THAT IS NOT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ALL HEALTH CENTERS
WILL HAVE RECEIVED TRAINING SO
THEY CAN BILL FOR THE PROCEDURE
THEY WILL NOT ONLY BE ABLE TO
PAY FOR THAT PROCEDURE. IT WILL
ALSO FUND THE HEALTH CARE CENTER
SLID EVEN MORE ALLY MORE
SERVICES CAN BE OFFERED TO
STUDENTS SO THERE SHOULD NEVER
BE AND NEED TO USE GENERAL FUND
MONIES.
WHAT ABOUT THE STUDENT FEES THE
OR STUDENT FEES? NONE OF THAT
SHOULD EVER BE NEEDED.
.
AND NOT YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A
VERY.
LIKE I SAID SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND I KNOW THAT NOT ONLY IS THE
PHYSICAL SIDE EFFECTS BUT THOSE
ALSO. YOU KNOW PSYCHOLOGICAL.
THEM DEPRESSION AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS AND.
I THINK YOU KNOW HAVING THESE
YOUNG STUDENTS
SOME OF THEM AS I SAID AWAY FROM
HOME FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IT'S.
AN ISSUE THAT.
IS GOES BEYOND JUST THE PHYSICAL
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL ON YOU KNOW I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. BUT I JUST WANT TO GET
THOSE THINGS OUT ON THE. IN THE
RECORD THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER.
CARILLO.
I THINK IT'S.
NOT WORKING FROM.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO
OUR ATTENTION I WOULD BE MORE
THAN HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL.
TO THE YOUNG WOMEN WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED TODAY.
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL OF
US THAT UNDERSTAND. THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF A DECISION THAT
YOU MAKE.
AND HOW THAT IMPACTS YOUR BODY
AND YOUR CHOICE.
WE ARE IN A TIME IN WHICH THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION IS
POTENTIALLY THE FUNDING SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. WHICH IS USUALLY A
PLACE WHERE YOU MIGHT GO FOR THE
SERVICES AND SO AS A STATE WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE
CARE OF ALL CALIFORNIANS IN
ENSURING THAT. THEIR ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH IS A PRIORITY.
TOO YOU KNOW I AM A WOMAN OF
FAITH.
AND FOR PERMISSION TO READ
MISTER CHAIR IF THAT'S OKAY.
I WANNA I WANTED TO SAY
SOMETHING THAT. POPE FRANCIS HAS
SHARED THAT IS VERY RELEVANT TO
THE TIMES IN WHICH WE LIVE IN
TODAY AND TO THE FOLKS. OUT THAT
ARE NOT SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN
FAITH I WOULD SAY.
POPE FRANCIS S. SAYS HAS SET.
OUR DEFENSE OF THE INNOCENT
UNBORN FOR EXAMPLE NEEDS TO BE
CLEAR FUHRMAN PASSIONATE.
EQUALLY SACRED HOWEVER. ARE THE
LIVES OF THE POOR THOSE ALREADY
BORN THE DESTITUTE THE ABANDONED
AND THE OTHER PRIVILEGE.
AND I REALLY DO.
IT CAME TODAY TO TESTIFY.
CAN TAKE THAT PASSION.
AND HELP OUR YOUNG CHILDREN WHO
ARE BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR
MOTHERS AT THE BORDER WHO ARE
CURRENTLY LIVING IN CAGES THERE
ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO CONSIDER. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY RIGHT NOW FOR THIS
BILL.
IS THE ABILITY FOR WOMEN TO HAVE
A RIGHT TO CHOOSE AND THAT NOT
ALL UNIVERSITIES ARE PLACES HAVE
ACCESS TO SOME OF THESE CLINICS
NEARBY NOT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO CARS TO
TRANSPORTATION.
AND THE EASIER WE MAKE IT.
IS A BETTER CHOICE FOR WOMEN AND
I DO UNDERSTAND AND KNOW THAT
THIS IS NOT AN EASY DECISION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
IT'S POWERFUL.
AND THAT THE ORANGE THAT DO WORK
AT THE CENTER ALSO SERVED AS
COUNSELORS AND CAN PROVIDE. THE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THAT IS NEEDED
WHEN MAKING THIS INCREDIBLY
TOUGH CHOICE
SO AGAIN THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
BRING IT TO OUR ATTENTION AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
MEMBERS OF THE LABOR. PARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TOPIC
CONVERSATION TO S.. AND OUT YOU
KNOW THIS THERE'S A STRONG
DEBATE HERE ABOUT CHOICE AND.
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND I GET
THAT BUT YOU KNOW FRANKLY MOST
THE TIME THAT WE MEET IN THIS
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
IT'S ABOUT ACCESS TO CARE AND
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO.
BASIC CARE PRIMARY CARE.
I WOMEN'S HEALTH REPRODUCTIVE
ISSUES.
AND I'M THINKING ABOUT THE ROLE
I DO OVERSEEING THAT FUNDING FOR
OUR UC'S IN CS USE STUDYING THAT
POPULATION.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF STUDENTS
VERY LOW INCOME. LOOK AT CSU
NEARLY TWO THIRDS.
VERY LOW INCOME.
AND SO THIS TO ME ISN'T ABOUT
CHOICE REPRODUCTIVE ISSUES
ABOUT.
HOUSE AND HAVE NOTS NEXT IF YOU
HAVE MONEY.
YOU CAN AFFORD TO GET ANY CARE
YOU WANT.
AND IF YOU DON'T YOU HAVE TO GET
ON A BUS MAYBE GO OF SIXTY
MINUTES.
ACROSS
TOWN EVEN IF HE IF HE IF YOU
HAVE THAT OPTION IT MAY MAYBE TO
HAVE A CARD ANOTHER CARD SO.
IT'S REALLY.
THAT ISSUE AS FAR AS.
.
ACCESS TO UP TO TWO TO HEALTH
CARE AND.
.
SOME HAVE IT SOME DON'T AND I
THINK THE CALIFORNIA BE MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYBODY.
HOW DOES HAVE ALL THE OPTIONS
THAT THE TO SIR THANK YOU? THANK
YOU SOMEONE MEMBER.
IT WAS MISTER IS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I APPRECIATE.
THE WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THIS.
I I'D BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T POINT OUT THAT.
I HOPE THE FUNDING ELEMENT OF
IT GETS WORK DOWN.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE LONG TERM.
UPSIDE TO HOPE THAT THAT. GETS
WORKED OUT AT SOME POINT.
OTHERWISE.
IT WOULD BE GOOD FOR THE
INTENTION TO BE STATED THAT AT
SOME POINT IT'LL BE TURNING OVER
TO.
GOVERNMENT SPONSORED WHICH I
WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF.
.
THAT SAID I ALSO JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND SAY THANK YOU
TO.
EVERYONE WHO DID SHOW UP
SOMETIMES IT'S DIFFICULT EVEN IF
YOU HEAR. A.
OPINIONS THAT YOU OPPOSE OR DO
NOT AGREE WITH.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO A TO
RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT OF FOLKS
LISTENING TO WHERE THEY WERE
COMING FROM WHETHER IT WAS. LOS
ANGELES RANCHO CUCAMONGA OR SAN
DIEGO OR.
AS FAR AWAY AS POSSIBLE.
TOOK THE TIME TO BE HERE TO
MAKE THEMSELVES HEARD SO I DO
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE EVERYONE
SHOWING UP.
REGARDLESS OF.
WHERE WE MAY FALLING OUR VIEWS?
SO WITH THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL. AND.
.
ASIDE FROM THE AT. ISSUE WHICH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY SPOKE OF.
I GUESS THIS IS TO SOMEWHAT.
MAYBE GIVE COMFORT TO TO THE
YOUNG LADY WHO WAS SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION.
.
IN AN ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS YOU
WON'T HAVE TO THEN BE.
AND.
THE BACKSIDE OF A GROCERY STORE.
AND A COLD ENVIRONMENT WAITING.
IT'LL BE IN A PURE ASSOCIATED
ENVIRONMENT.
SO I DO HOPE YOU SEE THAT
BENEFITS ALSO.
OF WITH THIS PROVIDES SO WITH
THAT I THINK YOU THINK YOU SOME
A MEMBER.
ANYONE ELSE.
YOUR BIGELOW.
YEAH I JUST WANTED A LITTLE
FOLLOW UP ON THE FUNDING
COMPONENT.
TO THE AUTHOR. YOU'VE GONE TO A
GREAT DEAL OF THE EXTENT TO.
BASICALLY SHOWCASED THIS BILL AS
IN NO COST TO THE. PUBLIC SECTOR
IF YOU WILL FROM THE GOVERNMENT
IN FACT IT GOES FAR TO STATE. IN
AT NINE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS MUST BE OBTAINED WE
HEARD TODAY AND TESTIMONY THAT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
OBTAINED AT THIS POINT. BUT
THERE'S AN ELEMENT WITHIN YOUR
BILL THAT TALKS.
ON PAGE SIX.
IF WE GO DOWN TO LINES TWENTY
THROUGH TWENTY TWO. WHERE IT
SPECIFICALLY STATES IN HERE
NOTHING IN THIS CHAPTER SHALL BE
INTERPRETED AS REQUIRING A
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY? TO UTILIZE
GENERAL FUND MONIES OR STUDENT
FEES FOR THE MEDICATION ABORTION
READINESS.
BEFORE JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWO.
BUT YOU'RE SILENT AFTER THAT.
WHICH LEAVES THE DOOR OPEN FOR
GOVERNMENT FUNDING SPONSORED.
ACTIVITIES LEADING TO THE
ABORTION.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT AND
CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE SO IT STAYS
IF IF THIS WAS YOUR TRUCK IT WAS
TO HAVE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
FUNDING?
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION SOMEONE MEMBER SO THAT
IS WHAT I REFERRED TO EARLIER
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
THAT EACH CAMPUS WILL BE TRAINED
ON HOW TO BILL FOR THIS
PROCEDURE. SO THEY WILL BILL AND
THEN THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THOSE MONEY SO THAT
THERE WON'T BE THE MONEY THAT'S
NEEDED FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE YOU
KNOW MY HISTORY GOES BACK QUITE
A WAYS WITH.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE LOCAL HEALTH. CLINICS
AND AND.
WHAT TYPICALLY? GENERALLY
HAPPENS IS THE HEALTH CARE FOLKS
HAVE VERY SYMPATHETIC HEARTS.
AND THE WIND UP OVER PROMISING
AND OVER PLEDGING RESOURCES.
TO THE POINT THAT THERE ARE ON
THE BRINK OF FULL COLLAPSE THERE
FOR. THE LOCAL BOARDS WIND UP
HAVING TO UTILIZE THEIR GENERAL
FUND TO SUBSIDIZE.
THOSE ACTIVITIES I WONDER SINCE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS.
THE COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES.
OUR PUBLICLY FUNDED.
WILL THEY NOT BE DOING THE SAME
THING WITH OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS.
BUT I WOULD A RESPONSE I WOULD
SAY THIS EVERY YEAR AT THE C.
ISSUES COME TO US AND ASK FOR
MONEY. AND EVERY YEAR WE
GENEROUSLY GIVE THEM MONEY
THAT'S WHY WE'VE CREATED A PATH
FOR THEM TO TRAIN THESE HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT FUNDING
SOURCE.
SO SOME I GUESS MY CLOSING
COMMENT.
WOULD BE.
I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD LOOK
AT.
FOR THE REFINING SO THAT WE
LIMIT THAT COMPLETE ABILITY FOR
THEM TO USE THE PUBLIC SECTOR
FUNDS.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD ASK YOU TO
LOOK AT DOING THAT AND AND
CLOSING THAT LOOPHOLE.
EN OPEN EXPOSURE ON THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT.
WE DON'T SEE IT IS A LOOPHOLE
BUT I'LL ACTUALLY REEVE AB
ABSOLUTELY REVIEWED AGAIN TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S NOTHING I'VE
MISSED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
IN NO ONE BRING IT BACK TO YOU
FOR YOUR AFTERNOON CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
TESTIFY BOTH IN SUPPORT. AN
OPPOSITION OF WHAT I ALWAYS LIKE
TO SAY TO PEOPLE THIS IS
DEMOCRACY IN ACTION AND THIS IS
WHY WE'RE ALSO LUCKY TO LIVE
WHERE WE LIVE.
ABORTION IS A CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED RIGHT WHETHER YOU
BELIEVE IN ABORTION ARE YOU
DON'T BELIEVE IN ABORTION IS A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT MAKING SURE
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY SAID
THAT ALL WOMEN HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
VERY EMOTIONAL ISSUE FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE. BUT THIS IS ALSO ABOUT
WOMEN CHOOSING WHEN THEY
INCORPORATE A FAMILY INTO THEIR
LIFE.
IF WE TRULY WANT WOMEN TO BE
EQUAL PARTNERS IN THIS WORLD WE
MUST MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THAT
CHOICE THEY HAVE THE CHOICE NOT
TO HAVE AN ABORTION.
THEY HAVE A CHOICE TO HAVE AN
ABORTION IS ARE BOTH ARTICULATE
YOUNG WOMEN WHO CHOSE DIFFERENT
COURSES AND WILL BOTH BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR LIFE BUT
THEY CHOSE OF COURSE. AND THEY
CHOSE WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO
WITH THEIR BODY WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER LEYVA
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES WHO CAME FROM FAR AND
WIDE.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE TO TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS
TODAY.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING ON A
VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE. AND FOR ME
THIS IS ABOUT ACCESS.
IT IS ABOUT CHOICE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THAT
FORWARD RECOGNIZE THAT ACCESS
NOT CHOICE IS NOT FOR EVERYONE
BUT FOR THOSE WHO WHO NEED WHO
WANT. TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THESE CRITICAL SERVICES I THINK
IT'S I THINK IT'S. IMPORTANT
THAT THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM SO
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. IT DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION
I DON'T LIKE THIS SECRETARY TO
IT'S TO PASS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
NOT SPENT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES NO TIGER CURRY. AGAR CURRY
I BIGELOW BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BURKE.
CARILLO AYE CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LIMON AYE FLOWN AYE MCCARTY. AYE
AYE MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
SYRIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. THURMOND
AYE BERMAN AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
NO.
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTES IT'S OUT OF
COMMITTEE.
WILL LEAVE THE ROLL UP FOR
OTHERS TO AND I THINK YOU GOT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
PORTANTINO
.
WHILE WHERE OF MOVING ON. TO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ANYONE WILLING TO
THANK.
MOTION BY.
I'M SORRY MISTER MISTER AS AARON
SECOND BY MISTER UP BIGELOW.
THEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGAR CURRY I THINK YOU'RE CREE
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LIMON. LIMON AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE NOSE AREA.
I'VE NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO THURMAN.
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
SO HAS TEN VOTES THE CONSENT
CAPCOM HERS APPROVED I WOULD
NOTE I APOLOGIZE I'M. THE LAST
THE FIRST A BILL S. B. THREE
TWENTY THE MOTION WAS MADE BY
MISTER THURMAN THE SECOND WAS
MADE BY MR MCCARTY JUST FOR THE
RECORD.
MR PARTICULAR SWITCHED YOU DON'T
MIND.
BE EASIER ON YOU
.
IT'S ALL GOOD
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
YOUR STAFF.
AND THE SPONSORS TO GET THE
BELT WHERE IT IS TODAY. I'M
PRESENTING S. B. THREE NINE NINE
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE SIGNIFICANT
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS IMPOSED BY
HEALTH PLANS. THAT ARE
PREVENTING WITH FAMILIES
PREVENTING FAMILIES FROM
ACCESSING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM.
THE BILL ALSO CODIFIES THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A CALLOUS A
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL AND PARA
PROFESSIONAL TO ENSURE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE.
STATISTICS TELL US THAT ONE IN
FIFTY NINE CHILDREN FOR TODAY
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM. EARLY
INTERVENTION IS THE KEY TO HELP
THESE CHILDREN'S LIVE UP TO
THEIR POTENTIAL ADDITIONALLY
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT IS
CRITICAL. NOT ALL CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM ARE THE SAME. THEY
RESPOND TO TREATMENT DIFFERENTLY
CHILDREN NEED TREATMENT TAILORED
TO THEIR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
PRESCRIBED BY THEIR PHYSICIAN
AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SCRIBE TREATMENT BY THEIR
PHYSICIAN OR PSYCHOLOGIST WHO
KNOWS THEM BASS
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
TREATMENT.
SEVEN YEARS AGO S. B. NINE FORTY
SIX PASSED THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM. IT HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
BUT MANY OTHERS HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED FROM RECEIVING ITS
BENEFITS.
BECAUSE OF A I BELIEVE A
DRAFTING ERROR AN ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS NOT EVERY CHILD IS
RECEIVING COVERAGE. FOR THE
TREATMENT THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS PRESCRIBE THAT.
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING DENIED COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBED. EVIDENCE BASED CARE
THIS IS COVERAGE THEY OR THEIR
EMPLOYERS HAVE ALREADY PAID FOR
BUT INTO MANY CASES.
THE PARENTS ARE STATE ARE LEFT
TO COVER THE COST OF THIS
CRITICAL CARE S. B. THREE NINE
NINE SEEKS TO CORRECT THIS
ERROR.
IN S. B. NINE FOUR SIX TO MAKE
SURE EVERY PERSON WITH AUTISM
HOUSE OUR HOUSE HEALTH COVERAGE
FOR THEIR MEDICALLY PRESCRIBED
TREATMENT.
THIS BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ACROSS THE STATE. RECEIVED OVER
THREE HUNDRED LETTERS FROM
PARENTSAND SUPPORT AS WELL AS
AND BY THE WAY I DIDN'T BRING
ALL THREE HUNDRED OF THEM I
FIGURED.
YOU HAD YOUR FILL OF HALLS BEING
FELT TODAY.
BUT WE COULD HAVE LETTERS FROM
PARENTS AND SUPPORT AS WELL AS
NUMEROUS AUTISM ORGANIZATIONS
AND PROFESSIONALS IN ADDITION
THE BILL IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
AUTISM BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
SPECIAL NEEDS NETWORK THE AUTISM
DESERVES EQUAL COVERAGE
FOUNDATION AND THE DIR FOR TIME
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA THE
SPONSORS REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN WITH AUTISM.
THEIR PARENTS AND THEIR
TREATMENT PROVIDERS.
.
AS A PARENT.
I THINK ABOUT WHEN MY CHILD HAS
ISSUES
I WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO SEE
TREATMENT THAT WILL BENEFIT. MY
CHILD IN EVERY OTHER CHILD NOT
EVERY SIZE FITS
ALL BOXES NOT EVERY CHILD SHOULD
FIT IN ONE SIZE OF TREATMENT OR
TALKING ABOUT MEDICALLY
NECESSARY. DOCTOR PRESCRIBED
TREATMENT I HAVE WITH ME JIM
LACHEY FROM THE D. I OUR
COALITION OF CALIFORNIANS AND
APPARENT CHRISTIAN CHANEL OF WHO
HERE TO ADD THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WOULD OF MY
NAME'S JIM LATCHAM WITH THE D.
OUR FLOOR TIME COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA BUT I REPRESENT ALL
FOUR CO SPONSORS.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT AS AS WAS
POINTED OUT IN THE.
THE ANALYSIS THERE ARE ABOUT
TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS AUTISM
ORGANIZATIONS FROM AROUND THE
STATE INCLUDING THE AUTISM
SOCIETY OF CALIFORNIA THAT
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
REPRESENTING THE WHOLE CROSS
SECTION OF THE AUTISM COMMUNITY
AYE AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
IS IS QUITE POINTED TO A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT IS
IT IS A WONDERFUL THING. IT.
HELPS CHILDREN A REACH THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL AND.
IT'S IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
ALLOW CHILDREN.
EARLY INTERVENTION TO REACH
THAT POTENTIAL.
TO TO TO HELP PRODUCTIVELY IVES.
TO TO REACH THEIR FULL PROMISE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
AFTER SENATE BILL NINE FORTY
SIX WAS PASSED.
THE PROMISE OF NINE FORTY SIX
WASN'T FULLY REALIZED.
THERE WERE TOO MANY OBSTACLES
OF SOME OF THE WORK DRAFTING
ERRORS.
BECAUSE THE BILL WAS WRITTEN AT
THE AND THE WANING HOURS OF THE
SESSION WE WE HAD TO WRITE THE
BILL THOUGH LAST MINUTE.
TO GET IT UNDER THE WIRE BEFORE
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WENT
INTO EFFECT.
AND THERE WERE SOME THINGS THAT
PROBABLY IF WE WERE WRITING THAT
TODAY WE WOULD HAVE WRITTEN
DIFFERENTLY.
THIS BILL.
CORRECTS SOME OF THOSE ERRORS.
IT TRIES TO FIX IT SO THAT MORE
CHILDREN CAN GET TREATMENT.
IT ADDS HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THAT ARE ALREADY REGULATED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
ALREADY RECOGNIZE IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALREADY WORKING
WITH REGIONAL CENTERS TO WORK
WITH CHILDREN WITH AUTISM AND
ALLOWS THEM TO BE COVERED UNDER
HEALTH INSURANCE TO PROVIDE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT. IN
OTHER FORMS OF AUTISM TREATMENT
OTHER THAN JUST SIMPLY ARE
APPLIED BEHAVIORAL ANALYSIS.
WHICH IS A VERY IMPORTANT.
BE ABLE HEALTH TREATMENT BUT
IT'S NOT THE ONLY ONE AS SENATOR
PORTANTINO SAID CHILDREN ARE
DIFFERENT.
THERE WAS A MOTHER WHO WANTED
TO BE HERE THIS MORNING
CHRISTMAS AFTERNOON TO SPEAK
WITH YOU UNFORTUNATELY SHE
COULDN'T GET CHILD CARE AND.
SHE HAS TWIN BOYS WITH AUTISM.
ANYBODY WHO HAS A CHILD WITH
AUTISM WILL TELL YOU THAT THAT'S
CRITICAL.
BUT.
.
SHE HAS TWIN BOYS WITH AUTISM
AND THEY'RE BOTH DIFFERENT.
SHE.
ONE OF THE BOYS.
.
RESPONDED VERY WELL TO APPLY
BEERBOHM ALICE'S
THE OTHER ONE DIDN'T.
SHE WENT BACK TO OUR DOCTOR
SAID HE KICKS HE SCREAMS HE
YELLS COULD HE HE'S HE'S
REGRESSING.
THE DOCTOR DID SOME RESEARCH AND
FOUND ANOTHER EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT.
PRESCRIBED THAT FOR HIM AND HE
DID DO VERY WELL UNDER IT
UNFORTUNATELY. IT WASN'T COVERED
BY INSURANCE
SAID THIS IS NOT COVERED.
SO I'M NOT GONNA DO IT SHE WENT
BACK TO HER REGIONAL CENTER THE
REGIONAL CENTER SAID YOU'VE BEEN
PRESCRIBED THIRTY HOURS A WEEK A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT HURT
YOU'VE BEEN PROVIDED.
COVERAGE FOR THIRTY HOURS OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT IT'S
ABA WORK THAT'S THAT'S FINE.
AND STATE OF THE SIX HOURS OF
DIR THAT.
YOUR DOCTOR PRESCRIBED THAT'S
FINE SHE PEELED IT.
TEN SECONDS
SHE APPEALED IT.
SHE ONE
STATES NOW PAIN FORT THE KIDS
DOING MARVELOUSLY.
THE POINT IS THE STATE'S PAIN
FORT THE KIDS DOING WELL.
IF THE PROFESSIONALS HAD BEEN
THERE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES.
THEN THE.
CLEARER.
INSURANCE COMPANY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PAID FOR IT AS WAS.
SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN THE CHILD
WOULD BEEN DONE AND THIS IS
HAPPENING THOUSANDS OF TIMES.
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WOODS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS SINCE CANNELLA I LIVE IN
MILL VALLEY AND I'M A MOTHER
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD BOY GIRL TWINS
MARK ON THE LIVE. BOTH OF WHOM
WERE NEUROTYPICAL AND AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
FRANCESCA WHO'S ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM.
I'M A CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST I
HAVE A MASTERS IN CHILD
PSYCHOLOGY AND CHILD DEVELOPMENT
AND A PHD IN CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGY.
WITH A CONCENTRATION BOTH IN
NEUROPSYCHOLOGY IN
PSYCHOANALYTIC PSYCHOTHERAPY.
I HAVE DRIVEN HERE TODAY TO TELL
YOU THE STORY FRANCESCA WHO BY
FOUR MONTHS WAS IN PHYSICAL
THERAPY BY NINE MONTHS IN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND SOON
AFTER IN SPEECH THERAPY.
ALTHOUGH I WAS A NEW MOTHER I
UNDERSTOOD FROM THE BEGINNING
THAT SHE WAS NOT DEVELOPING IN A
TYPICAL MANNER.
FROM AGES ZERO TO SEVEN
FRANCESCO OFTEN HAD SEVEN OR
EIGHT FAIR BEATS PER WEEK. BASED
ON MY EXPERIENCE AS A CLINICIAN
IN AS HER MOTHER.
THE ONLY THERAPIES THAT EVER
MADE SENSE FOR HER WERE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL RELATIONSHIP BASED
THERAPIES
SHE CRAVED REAL CONNECTION AND
UNDERSTANDING HER WORLD.
IN ADDITION TO HER WEEKLY AND
OFTEN TWICE WEEKLY OTP T. AND
SPEECH THERAPIES.
HERE JUST A FEW OF THE
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS I PUT
TOGETHER FOR HER DURING HER
EARLY YEARS.
SHE ATTENDED A FULL INCLUSION
PRESCHOOL IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
THE TEACHERS WERE ALSO EXPERTS
AND DEVELOPMENTAL RELATIONSHIP
BASED THERAPIES FOR CHILDREN ON
THE SPECTRUM.
SHE HAD YEARS OF DEVELOPMENTAL
RELATIONSHIP RELATIONAL ONE ON
ONE THERAPY AS WELL AS TWICE
WEEKLY RELATIONSHIP BASED PLAY
THERAPY IN OUR HOME WITH TWIN
GIRLS WHO ARE FRANCESCA'S AGE
BUT WHO WERE NEUROTYPICAL.
I ALSO TRAVELED REGULARLY TO THE
MIND INSTITUTE TO MEET WITH AN
INCREDIBLE DEVELOPMENTAL
PEDIATRICIAN AND HER TEAM OF
THERAPISTS ROOTED IN
RELATIONSHIP BASED
INTERVENTIONS.
ALL OF THIS IS YOU CAN IMAGINE
WAS VERY TIME CONSUMING AND VERY
COSTLY.
BUT FRANCESCA'S WORLD WAS
OPENING UP.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING OF LIFE
SHE HAD THERAPIST WHO USE THESE
DEVELOPMENTAL IN RELATIONSHIP
THERAPEUTIC APPROACHES TO HELP
HER EXPAND HER CIRCLES OF
COMMUNICATION. OUR INTERESTS
HER PERSPECTIVE TAKING AND WHO
THEREFORE DEEPENED HER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORLD.
FRANCESCA WILL TURN NINETEEN
THIS SUMMER.
SHE IS NOW AN ADULT WHO HAS
FRIENDSHIPS WHO TRAVELS BY
HERSELF TO THE EAST COAST TO
VISIT FAMILY. WHO USED TO TAKE
THE TRAIN REGULARLY IN THE GRAND
CENTRAL STATION AND MEET HER
FATHER WHO GOES AWAY TO SUMMER
CAMP WHO WORKS AT A PRESCHOOL
WHO APPLIES TO JOBS ALL THE
TIME?
IS A T. A IN HER CLASS SHE COOKS
CLEANS DOES LAUNDRY GOES ALL
OVER MARIN COUNTY IN THE BUS BUT
OF COURSE WOULD PREFER UBER.
CHAU GRADUATE NEXT YEAR.
FROM HIGH SCHOOL SHE WANTS TO GO
TO COLLEGE TO BECOME A NURSE'S
ASSISTANT. THAT MAY BE A REACH
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO BE THE ONE
TO CLOSE THE DOOR ON HER.
FRANCESCA IS WHERE SHE IS NOW
BECAUSE SHE RECEIVED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT THAT IS NOT
COVERED BY HEALTH INSURANCE BUT
SHOULD BE.
SHE RECEIVED TREATMENT THAT
ALLOWED HER TO GROW INTO A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF SOCIETY AND
THERE ARE SO MANY FRANCESCA'S
OUT THERE I'VE WORKED WITH THOSE
FAMILIES IN MY PRIVATE PRACTICE.
I'VE HEARD THE PLIGHTS OF
HUNDREDS OF MOTHERS WHO WANT
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR CHILD BUT
CANNOT AFFORD IT.
FRANCESCA IS LIVING PROOF OF THE
POWER OF EVIDENCE BASED
DEVELOPMENTAL RELATIONSHIP BASED
APPROACHES.
AND I KNOW WITHOUT A SHADOW OF A
DOUBT
SHE IS ONLY WHERE SHE IS TODAY
BECAUSE OF ALL OF HER YEARS OF
EARLY RELATIONSHIP BASED
INTERVENTION.
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CERTAIN ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WHERE WE HAVE?
WE HAD. WAS A HAVE SUPPORTED HIM
ESPECIALLY THOSE I'M SORRY I
WASN'T IT IN ME TO JUMP THE GUN
PLEASE I'M SORRY. FOREHEAD.
LIZ WELL THEN SPEECH
PATHOLOGISTS HEAD OF SCHOOL THE
HELIX SCHOOL I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE THE SERVICES.
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
LIZ MCDONOUGH CLINICAL DIRECTOR
OF THE HELIX SCHOOL.
MARGARET MORRIS FOUNDER. OF THE
HEALING SCHOOL.
AND A SON WITH AUTISM.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
POSITION.
YEAH.
SO WE HAVE TO WITNESSES THREE
MINUTES IN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MISSY
JOHNSON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS IS A
TRADE ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS PROVIDERS OF AB
SERVICE SAYS. I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY MATT MCCLEARY WHO'S THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS A BOARD
CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS.
BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE SPONSORS OF
THE LEGISLATION THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL ARE PROBLEMATIC TO
US FOR RIGHT HERE REASONS BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT.
THE LANGUAGE WAS NOT A DRAFTING
ERROR IN BOTH THE ORIGINAL OF
MANDATE LEGISLATION AND
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION THAT HAD
BEEN INTRODUCED PREVIOUSLY THAT.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON OUR CONCERNS
WITH SP SB THREE NINETY NINE
CURRENTLY REVOLVE AROUND THE
LANGUAGE RELATED TO THE
QUALIFIED ARTISANS.
PROFESSIONAL THE MIDDLE TIER IN
OUR SERVICE DELIVERY MODEL.
WHICH IS SUPERVISED BY A
LICENSED OR CERTIFIED INDIVIDUAL
BUT ALSO HAS THE ABILITY TO
CREATE THAT'S LANGUAGE AND TEN
SEVENTY FOR THE PAST LAST YEAR
TO SUPERVISE INDEPENDENTLY PARA
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL FOLKS.
OF MANY PEOPLE WITH AUTISM AND
RELATED DISORDERS EXHIBIT
BEHAVIORS OF DIRECTLY JEOPARDIZE
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
SUCH BEHAVIOR IS OFTEN RESULT IN
COSTLY LARGELY INEFFECTIVE USE
EDUCATION EMERGENCY ROOM
SERVICES HOSPITALIZATIONS.
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES ETCETERA.
SUBSTANTIAL YOU SHOULD RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT COMPETENTLY DESIGNED
AND DELIVERED INTERVENTIONS ARE
EFFECTIVE FOR REDUCING PROBLEM
BEHAVIORS.
CONVERSELY RESEARCHERS SHOWN THE
INTERVENTIONIST TO LACK
SUFFICIENT TRAINING CONNECTION
INCREASE THE OCCURRENCE OF
BEHAVIORS OF PEOPLE WITH AUTISM.
OUR MAJOR CONCERN IS THAT THE
POOL OF PROVIDERS HAS BEEN
EXPANDED SIGNIFICANTLY. TO
INCLUDE IN TERMS AND A SYSTEM
LEVEL FOLKS WHO HAVE. LITTLE
COURSEWORK LITTLE SUPERVISION IN
THEIR.
EXCUSE ME THERE SUPERVISED FIELD
WORK AND LITTLE CONTENT ON THEIR
LICENSURE EXAMS OF REGARDING.
BEAVER NELSON TREATMENT LOTS OF
THEM.
SO WITHOUT SUFFICIENT MINIMUM
STANDARDS PRACTICE COMPETENTLY
CONSUMERS ARE AT AN INCREASED
RISK OF HARM FROM INDIVIDUALS
MAKING FALSE CLAIMS.
TO BE QUALIFIED TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES.
THE AUTHORING SPONSORS HAVE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS AT THE PARA
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL. TO SEPARATE
THE CRITERIA FOR THOSE PROVIDING
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYTICS
SERVICES.
AND OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENTS.
THE ENDS OF WELL WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT CONFUSIONS COULD
COST REGULATORS AND FUNDERS WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS TO CONSIDER DOING THE
SAME FOR THAT A PROFESSIONAL
LEVEL. THAT FREE TIME.
I GOOD AFTERNOON I CHAIRMAN
WOULD AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON JENNIFER ALLEN WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS.
MIGHT WANNA BE CLEAR THAT
HEALTH PLANS CURRENTLY COVER
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS.
BY SCIENTIFIC A SCIENTIFICALLY
PROVEN APPROACH AS RECOMMENDED
BY BEST PRACTICE GUIDELINES.
THIS BILL RECENTLY AMENDED A AND
AMENDED AGAIN FIGHT WITH EVEN
WITH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WOULD REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO
COVER TREATMENT TYPES OUTSIDE OF
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS.
THAT ARE EXPERIMENTAL AND NOT
RECOMMENDED FOR AUTISM CARE.
YOU KNOW MANAGED CARE RELIES ON
ENSURING THAT AND RELEASE
RECEIVE THE APPROPRIATE SERVICE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND THAT
MEANS THAT MUST ADHERE TO
CLINICAL GUIDELINES.
WE THEREFORE MUST OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
ITS EXPANSIVE AND COSTLY MANDATE
BILL BECAUSE IT IGNORES CURRENT.
MEDICAL EDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AND BEST PRACTICE GUIDELINES.
AND SO WE'RE JUST VERY VERY
CONCERNED. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE PAIR
PARTICIPATION WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT THOSE AMENDMENTS I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY WILL REMOVE
OPPOSITION OUR CONCERNS WITH
THAT SECTION OF THE BILL.
.
YOU KNOW. AS FOR THE LOCATION
LANGUAGE AS A CLARIFICATION
LANGUAGE THAN PREVIOUS VERSIONS
OF AMENDMENTS OF THE BELT KIND
OF TRIED TO CLARIFY THAT HEALTH
PLANS WOULD NOT PAY FOR SERVICES
PAID BY SKIP SCHOOLS.
STILL AND THE LIMITATION TO THE
PLAN SERVICE AREA STILL CAUSES
SOME CONCERN. YOU KNOW OUR PLANS
AND OUR CLINICIANS AB THE HEALTH
PLAN UTILIZED VARIOUS TOOLS TO
EVALUATE WHAT PLANTS ARE
COVERING IT TYPICALLY HEALTH
PLANS COVER CARE IN PROVIDER
OFFICES STATE PROGRAMS CLINICS
AND AND THEN RELEASE HOME WHEN
IT COULD BE. PROPERLY STRUCTURED
TO SUPPORT THE OPTIONAL BENEFIT
FOR THE CHILD.
TOM YOU KNOW THE LIMITATION ON
HEALTH PLANS ABILITY TO REVIEW
REGARDING PARENT PARTICIPATION
AND THE LOCATION REMAINS A
PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT A CHILD.
WHICH.
DOES BETTER WHEN THEIR PARENTS
PARTICIPATES IN THEIR CARE IN
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE ADDED LANGUAGE
AMENDMENTS TO SAY THAT IT'S
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE. I WOULD
ARGUE WE DON'T HAVE ANY MEDICAL
LITERATURE THAT SAYS THAT IT IS
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PARENT TO BE ENGAGED.
AND SO I THINK IT'S JUST IT'S
SOMETHING AND IT'S A REAL
CONCERN FOR US.
.
AND WE ECHO THE CONCERNS ON
WATERING DOWN THE PROVIDER
REQUIREMENTS THAT WAS DISCUSSED
BY. THE
WITNESSES PRIOR TO BE THINKING.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
DISTRICT NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
STEPHANIE WATKINS ON THE HAVE
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES ALSO.
THE ONLY BE DRAWN WITH WHICH YOU
CUT CAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION.
Q..
KEPT CAPTIVE MUST REVERSING THE
LOCAL PLANS TO CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE F.
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
ARE STRUGGLING OPPOSITION.
MICHELLE HI I'M A BOARD
CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS AND WE OPPOSE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU ALL MELISSA COURT HAS
ROTH ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
AUTISM RELATED DISORDERS I'M
ACTUALLY HERE TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WHILE WE
DO SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
THAT WAS OUTLINED BY KELLY ABA
WE'VE YOU THE IN THEM THAT'S AS
A COMPROMISE TO SORT OF SEPARATE
OUT SEPARATE OUT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS FOR APPLIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS. AND WHAT MAY
BE OTHER EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENTS THANK YOU.
PRE PACKED
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WAS YOUR BILL AMENDMENTS.
MR IS AARON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I CARRIED
A SIMILAR BILL TO THIS.
I THINK A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
AND AND I.
SO WHAT COULDN'T UNDERSTAND THE%
ARGUMENTS MADE AT THAT TIME AND
I THINK.
THIS IS BEEN A BILL THAT'S
EVEN WORKED AND BE COME TO A
BETTER PLACE THAN THE ONE I WAS
WORKING ON.
SO I'M I'M SUPPORTING IT I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AND.
.
I I I SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS HAVE
STILL STAYED THE SAME.
AND EVEN WHEN I'M READING IT AND
LOOKING AT. YOUR SAYING THAT
IT'S EXPAND THE AT SCHOOL WATER
DOWN BUT IT'S ALSO RAISED COSTA
HOW'S IT GONNA RAISE COSTS IF
IT'S WATERED DOWN.
BUT IS A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTRADICTORY MESSAGES HERE SO.
IF YOU WANT TO TOUCH ON IT BE
HAPPY TO HEAR IT OUT BUT I ALSO
FEEL THAT.
EVEN WITH THE IMPROVEMENTS MADE.
THE ARGUMENTS ARE STILL THE
SAME.
SO.
CARE TO ELABORATE OR. ADDRESS
THAT. YOU KNOW I'M HAPPY TO SO
IF.
IF A PLAN IDENTIFIES THE PARENT
IS A PARTICIPATING IN THEIR
CHILDCARE FOR EXAMPLE. AND.
THAT CHILD IS FAILING TO.
.
PROGRESS IN THEIR TREATMENT
GOALS MY WE'RE TALKING A YEAR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TWO YEARS INTO
TREATMENT AND THEY'RE STILL
HAVEN'T PROGRESSED AS THEY
SHOULD BASED ON THEIR DIAGNOSIS
AND. EXPERIENCE WITH APPLIED
BEAT YOU KNOW WITH THAT THE. A
PROVIDERS HAVE YOU COULD
QUESTION IS IT BECAUSE THE
PARENTS ARE PARTICIPATING AND SO
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF THE PARENTS
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THAT CHILD
DOESN'T PROGRESS.
MY NUMBER'S CONCERN IS THAT THE
HOURS THEY'RE CURRENTLY GETTING
TWENTY HOURS OF ABA WEEK THAT
THEY'RE GONNA GET THIRTY OR
THIRTY FIVE OR FORTY. SOMETHING
IS GOING TO HAVE TO.
HAPPENED HER CURVE TO MAKE UP
FOR THE DEFICIT THE PARAMOUNT
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR TREATMENT
AND THAT WILL INCREASE COSTS.
AND. THROUGH THIS HAIRCUT MAY AT
A ONE OF THE REASONS THE
ARGUMENTS HAVE REMAINED THE SAME
IS BECAUSE THE ISSUE HAS
REMAINED THE SAME ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WATERING DOWN THE
STANDARDS IS SIMPLY THIS IF YOU
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT
QUALIFIED. TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND THERE'S
NO DEMONSTRATED AYE IMPROVEMENT
TO THE SERB ADD TO THE CHILD'S
BEHAVIOR THOSE CHILDREN THEN AND
UP REQUIRING ADDITIONAL SERVICES
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN NEEDED.
HAD THEY RECEIVE THE APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
THAT IS THE CORE OF OUR CONCERN
ABOUT THE WATERING DOWN OF THE
REQUIREMENTS. AS MATT AT THE
ENUMERATED WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT OF THE THE WATER DOWN
EDUCATIONAL IN SPIRIT.
EXPERIENCE OR REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISHED BY THE BILL.
Q..
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY RESPOND OR
DO YOU WANT TO DO TO MY CLOTHES
YOU CLOSE IF YOU DON'T ANSWER
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
A SERVICE WE DON'T.
I'M JUST KIND OF FOLLOWING A KID
ON OUR COLLEAGUE OVER HERE.
ON COTS.
MEDI CAL YOU FLY EXCLUDED MEDI
CAL ON A REIMBURSEMENT COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THAT TO US.
THAT'S EXISTING LAW.
OKAY SOBRE WHY ARE WE NOT.
WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS COMPLY
WITH EXISTING LAWS POSSIBLE IN
OUR FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WHEN
THE ORIGINAL LAW WAS DRAFTED
THERE WAS A DRAFTING ERROR ON
THE TREATMENT SIDE.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS SO WERE TRYING TO BE
AS RESPECTFUL TO EXISTING LAWS
POSSIBLE ACROSS THE BOARD AND
THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS.
WITH RECOGNIZING THAT I SEE THE
PLANS WHEN A PROBABLY RESPOND AS
WELL.
IF I COULD MISTER CHAIRMAN
GRABBED HIM TO RESPOND.
SURE.
WHAT WOULD YOU MIND RESPONDING
TO THAT? AND THANK YOU SO I MEDI
CAL CURRENTLY COVERS ON AUTISM
SERVICES IT'S IN THE STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT AND IT'S PART OF THE
MEDI CAL CONTRACTS.
THE RACIAL INITIAL AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION OTHER STEINBERG BELL
SEVERAL YEARS AGO DID NOT
INCLUDE MEDICARE BUT MEDI CAL
WAS INCLUDED INCLUDED ARE ADDED.
THAT COVERAGE WAS ADDED THROUGH
BUDGET TRAILER BILL THE
FOLLOWING YEAR.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THIS BILL
YOU KNOW STATES THAT MEDIC HOUSE
EXCLUDED BUT ACTUALLY ALL THE
COSTS AND THE CONCERN ON THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE MY MEDI CAL
MEMBERS ALSO HAVE.
BECAUSE EVEN IF THEY'RE
EXCLUDED FROM THESE PROVIDER
REQUIREMENTS AND THE CHANGES IT
WILL.
WITH CONTINUITY OF CARE IS
MEMBERS GO FROM OUT OTHER
COVERAGE BACK TO MEDI CAL THAT
THESE UP PROVISION REQUIREMENTS
WOULD ALSO LIKE.
SO FOLLOWING UP WITH THAT.
.
WELL MAYBE THAT CARS OF
CLARIFIES I THINK THAT IF I DO
YOU WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH THAT.
YEMENI RESPONSE TO.
THOSE COMMENTS JUST COUNT IF NOT
HAVE A SECOND.
WELL I THINK. WE DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH CLARIFYING THAT
PIECE OF IT I MEAN YOU KNOW OUR
OUR GOAL IS NOT TO UNDO.
THE EXISTING FRAMEWORK IT'S JUST
TO PROVIDE OPTIONS FOR PARENTS
SO.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
BUT LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN REACH
OUT TO EVERYONE SERVICE EVERYONE
I'M JUST WONDERING WHY YOU'RE
EXCLUDING ONE SEGMENT.
A SECTION.
I AM SO BACK TO THE. PART ABOUT
REQUIREMENTS HOUSE CHANGING THE
PROVIDER REQUIREMENTS ARE
ESTABLISHING DIFFERENT.
FLOOR TIME PROVIDER TYPE
REQUIREMENTS PUBLIC
REIMBURSEMENT HELPING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHAT?
RIGHT NOW ONLY ONE TYPE OF
TREATMENT.
IT'S COVERED.
SO IF YOU'RE A PARENT AND YOUR
DOCTOR PRESCRIBES.
ANOTHER TREATMENT THAT'S.
EVIDENCE BASED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY YOU HAVE TO
PAY OUT OF POCKET FOR.
OKAY SOME OF THE DEVELOP.
MY NO SERVICES HAVE.
.
CREATED A CRITERIA.
IS THAT NOT PART OF THE FOLLOW
UP.
IS THAT NOT PART OF THE PROCESS
SO WHAT'S BEEN LACKING HERE.
WHERE WE MET THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S WHERE WERE THAT'S WHERE
THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT ON
DRAFTING ERROR VERSE NO
TRACKING?
IT'S OUR CONTENTION THAT WHEN
THIS WAS ENVISIONED IT WAS NOT
ENVISIONED AS A MONOPOLY.
KATE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
MONOPOLY.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WHAT THE
HEART OF THIS BILL IS VERY.
IT'S BECOME.
MORE COMPLICATED BECAUSE IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS ARYAN WE'VE
WORKED.
FOR FOUR YEARS I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID IT FOR TWO.
.
AND THEN FOR THE LAST TWO. WE'VE
TRIED TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THE
NUANCES AND THE CONCERNS BUT THE
HEART OF THE BILL IS VERY
SIMPLE.
THE HEART OF THE BILL IS YOUR
PHYSICIAN.
PRESCRIBES
A MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT.
AND WHETHER THAT SHOULD BE
COVERED ARE NOT COVERED UNDER
EXISTING LAW ONLY ONE IS
COVERED.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU
HAVE A CHILD OR GRANDCHILD AND
THAT CHILD'S PHYSICIAN.
DESCRIBES A NOW THEIR TREATMENT.
U. S. APPARENT DON'T HAVE TO SAY
WELL I HAVE TO GO TO THIS ONE
THAT MAY NOT BE EFFECTIVE FOR
THIS CHILD.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY ONE THAT
I GET REIMBURSED.
SO WE'RE ANALYZE A COMPLEX SINCE
EXISTING PROVIDER REQUIREMENTS
WE ESTABLISHED BY THE DDS.
.
IN FACT SAID THAT HAVE YOU
SPOKEN TO THE DDS. AND WHAT WERE
SOME OF THEIR THOUGHTS IN
RESPONSE TO CHANGING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS.
YEAH.
I'M SORRY I I DON'T SO I DON'T
MEAN TO CATCH OFF GUARD IF YOU
DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER THAT'S
FINE.
THE PROBLEM LIES IN IN THE WAY
THAT THROUGH THE. NINE FORTY SIX
WAS WRITTEN IS THE PROVIDERS.
THE WAY THE THE BILL DISK
DEFINES A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT IT SAYS ALL EVIDENCE
BASE TREATMENTS THAT ARE
PRESCRIBED BY A PHYSICIAN OR A
PSYCHIATRIST.
I AM SORRY PSYCHOLOGIST.
BETTER.
PROVIDED BY IN THAT IT GIVES
THREE TIERS OF PROVIDERS
THE FIRST PROVIDER EVERYBODY'S
OKAY WHICH IS LICENSE HEALTH
PROVIDERS DOCTORS.
PSYCHOLOGISTS OF MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPISTS COUNSELORS AND
BOARD CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSTS FOR
PROVIDE ABA.
BUT THOSE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THEY
ACTUALLY SUPERVISE OTHERS WHO
DO.
THEN THE NEXT YEAR ARE THE
PROFESSIONALS AND THAT'S WHERE
WE RUN INTO THE PROBLEM.
BECAUSE WE WERE WRITING THE THAT
THAT BILL WAS WRITTEN LATE IN
THE SESSION THEY TOOK THE
EXISTING VENDOR CODES FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTERS FROM TITLE
SEVENTEEN. AND ALL OF THOSE WERE
ABA RELATED COATS
AND THAT'S WHERE WE SAY WE
CONTEND THAT IT WAS A DRAFTING
ERROR.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A BE A
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS
FIVE THE ACTUAL CODE NUMBERS
THAT WERE CITED IN THE ORIGINAL
BILL AND NARROWED IT TO ONLY ONE
TYPE AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM AND
THEN. THE THIRD PROVIDE OF PROOF
PROVIDER LEVEL LISTA PARA
PROFESSIONAL.
AND AGAIN IT'S CITED TO TITLE
SEVENTEEN CODE AND AGAIN THOSE
ARE ABA RELATED.
COATS.
AND AS A RESULT THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES LOOKING AT SAYING WELL
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THE SERVICES.
HAVE TO BE ABA TRAINED THERE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE MUST ADMIT ABA
AND SO IF YOU'RE PROVIDE IF YOU
PRESCRIBE ANYTHING ELSE WE DON'T
HAVE TO COVER IT.
AND THAT'S AND THEREIN LIES THE
PROBLEM IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
IT'S NOT EVIDENCE BASED IT JUST
MEANS THERE ISN'T ANYBODY TO
PROVIDE SO BY PROVIDING THESE
ALREADY REGULAR STATE REGULATED
PROFESSIONS.
WHO BY THE WAY ARE MASTERS LEVEL
WORKING ON THEIR DOCTORATES AND
WHEN THEY GET THEIR DOCTORS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN THE
PROVIDER LEVEL THEY'RE ALREADY
LISTED IN THE LEGISLATION IN THE
PROVIDER LEVEL ONCE THEY GET
THEIR DOCTORATES?
BUT.
THEY THEY'RE ALREADY WORKING
WITH REGIONAL CENTERS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES.
THERE WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AND THEN THEY WILL EXPAND AND BE
ABLE TO DO THAT THAT BUT THEY
HAVE TO BE TRAINED IN THE EAST
AND THE BAY REAL HEALTH
TREATMENT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING.
THAT WILL THEREIN LIES THE
ANSWER RIGHT NOW VERY MUCH THAT
HELPS A LITTLE BIT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS.
COULD COULD I ASK YOU BECAUSE I
SEE THAT YOU GOODNESS THERE TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU FOR READING THIS IF
YOU CAN.
HARD TO GET A COUPLE STEPS BACK
I THINK AT THE ROOT OF THE ISSUE
AND WE HAVEN'T BROUGHT UP THIS
ARGUMENT THIS YEAR WE HAVE IN
THE PAST.
IS IT NOT FORTY SIX
STATES THAT YOU CAN.
FUND.
FUNDERS TO PAY FOR APPLIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS OR OTHER
EVIDENCE BASED BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENTS.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT THE FUNDERS
HERE ARE SORT OF THE PROVIDERS.
THE PLANS ARE NOT WILLING TO PAY
FOR ANYTHING THAT THEY DO NOT
TEAM EVIDENCE BASED.
AND TO APPLY BEHAVE ANALYSIS HAS
A RICH EVIDENCE BASED MANY OF
THESE OTHER TREATMENTS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED HERE. ARE HAVE
FORTHCOMING EVIDENCE OR EMERGING
EVIDENCE BUT THEY HAVEN'T REACH
THAT THRESHOLD.
AND AS IT RELATES YOUR QUESTION.
REGARDING CHANGING AT THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PROVIDERS
CHANGING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE PROVIDERS DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE FUNDAMENTAL
THRESHOLD PROBLEM. ABOUT THESE
OTHER TREATMENTS BEING EVIDENCE
BASED.
WITH THAT DISTRICT HANCOCK.
IF.
ANYONE ELSE.
MISS WALDRON.
I FEEL LIKE THIS HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO GET CLOSE HAVE A
HOME.
YOU'VE GOTTEN THROUGH SOME
AMENDMENTS.
I MEAN YOU'RE STILL WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION.
THIS IS GOES FORWARD WE WILL
MEET WITH ANYONE ANYWHERE EVERY
DAY. I THINK THAT MY CONCERN AND
TRY AND THAT'S WHY THE BILL IS
INVOLVED TO WHERE IT'S AT YEAH I
MEAN WHAT WE TALK ABOUT ACCESS
ALL THE TIME AND NOW. WHAT I'M
PROVIDE THE SERVICE?
AND THERE'S NO ISSUES WITH THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT'S IN NO.
THOSE CERTAIN TYPE OF TREATMENT
VERSUS ANOTHER.
ONE IN FIFTY I WANT TO SEE SOME
KIND OF
RESOLUTION I'M.
STRUGGLING WITH.
YOU KNOW.
CAN WE GET THERE I DON'T KNOW
BUT I. I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU
IN THE.
THREE PLUS YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
FOR MAYOR WITH THIS PROCESS AND
I GO BACK TO WHEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOES AREA HAD IT.
BECAUSE I KNOW SOME OF THE
PARENTS THAT. WERE ADVOCATES FOR
WHEN HE CARRIED THE BILL.
IT HAS BEEN A FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
OF FRANKLY.
.
A MONOPOLY. WE HAVE TRIED AND WE
HAVE TAKEN
MANY MANY MANY SETS OF
AMENDMENTS AND I KNOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HIS ARYAN DID. BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY YOU HAVE A.
PROVIDER WHO WANTS TO MAINTAIN A
MONOPOLY BECAUSE.
WE KEEP BOTH SAYING EVIDENCE
BASED.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL SAYS.
SO IF.
WE SUPPORT EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT THERE SHOULD BE NO
DISCUSSION THERE SHOULD BE NO
ARGUMENT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DOCTOR
PRESCRIBED.
AGAIN THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL.
IS IN CHARGE.
OF THAT FAMILIES HEALTH.
SAYING WE THINK YOUR SON OR
DAUGHTER.
WHAT RESPOND WELL TO THIS
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT OVER
THIS ONE?
IT SHOULD BE COVERED.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE KEY POINT
WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT
EXPERIMENTAL RETIREMENT EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENT. BUT UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
ONLY ONE OF THOSE EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENTS
QUALIFIES.
FOR INSURANCE COVERAGE.
THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL PIECE
SO WITHIN DEFINITIONS WERE OPEN
TO THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE SHOWN THAT FOR TWO YEARS
AND BEYOND.
BUT AT SOME POINT. THERE'S A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIVIDE OVER
WHETHER WE SHOULD HAVE A
MONOPOLY.
AND OFTEN TREAT ALL CHILDREN THE
SAME WAY OR WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE
THAT EVERY CHILD IS DIFFERENT
AND WHITE RESPOND TO DIFFERENT
TREATMENTS DIFFERENTLY. UNDER
THE CARE OF THEIR PEDIATRICIAN.
WELL THAT'S WHY THEY SAY THIS
POSSUM SPECTRUM BECAUSE NOT
EVERY CHILD RESTING PLACE.
I HAVE A VERY DEAR FRIEND WHOSE
SON HAS AUTISM AN. YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'VE HAD TO GO THROUGH. AND
YOU'D WANT ESPECIALLY IN THE
DEVELOPING YOU WANT TO GET THE
TREATMENT TO THEM AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE RIGHT AND IT COULD BE
SOMETHING LIKE COMING A PUPPY.
CORRECT LISTENING TO MUSIC YOU
KNOW HAVING SOMEONE WHO CAN
TEACH THEM.
SOMETHING THAT THAT YOU KNOW
MAYBE IT'S NOT. TAKING A DRUG OR
DAY MAYBE IT'S A COUNSELOR WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO. YOU KNOW
BABIES LEARNING A SIGN LANGUAGE
OR SOMETHING A DIFFERENT WAY TO
COMMUNICATE. WHAT THEY'RE
FEELING THAT WOULD HELP THEM
HEAL SO THAT'S WHY I ADMIT THE
FRUSTRATION AVOCET THAT FEEL
LIKE IT COULD BE CLOSE? AND
YOU'VE COME THIS FAR.
SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK OUT I
MEAN I I CAN'T TELL YOU. IF
THERE'S A SPECIFIC PIECE OF
LANGUAGE BUT WE HAD A MEETING
YESTERDAY I MEAN WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
AND THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
OF WORKED AS WELL I MEAN.
THIS IS THIS IS NOW THE SECOND.
HEALTH COMMITTEE OF A SIX YEAR
JOURNEY.
THE MEMBERS.
MANY MARK IF THANK YOU MISTER.
.
MAYBE THIS WHOLE CRUX REVOLVES
AROUND DDS IF THEY WOULD JUST
SIMPLY.
DO AN UPDATE TO THEIR
REGULATIONS%
AND MAKE IT CLEARER MIGHT BE
HELPFUL.
TO ALL PARTIES AFFECTED IS JUST
RHETORICAL. ACT RESHAPE THE
AUTHOR AND IN EVERYONE'S A
COMMENT HERE TODAY.
ANYONE ELSE.
NO ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
WOULD TO THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR THE ROBUST DISCUSSION I YOU
KNOW.
WHO AMONGST US DOESN'T KNOW A
FAMILY OR HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
WHO HASN'T BEEN AFFECTED?
BY ARTISTS WHO AMONGST US
DOESN'T HAVE.
A RELATIVE OR TWO I MEAN I HAVE
TWO DAUGHTERS AND THEY ARE NIGHT
AND DAY.
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
DIFFERENT HUMAN BEINGS.
TO ME I'M ASKING YOU TO THINK
OF THIS YES AS A LEGISLATURE.
LEGISLATOR BUT ALSO THINK OF IT
AS A PARENT A GRANDPARENT AN
AUNT OR AN UNCLE. AND THINK
ABOUT YOUR PEDIATRICIAN PULLING
YOU INTO. YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER
GRANDCHILD'S.
ROOM AND SAYING I WOULD LIKE TO
SEND THEM OUT TO A TREATMENT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT
COVERED BY YOUR INSURANCE
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT INTO THE
MONOPOLY BOX.
BUT I THINK YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER
WOULD RESPOND WELL. TO THAT
TREATMENT.
AND SO YOU DIG DEEP AND YOU PAY
FOR THAT TREATMENT YOURSELF
ALONE BEHOLD YOUR CHILD COMES
HOME.
AND ACTUALLY IS RESPONDING TO
THAT OTHER TREATMENT BECAUSE IT
IS EVIDENCE BASED BECAUSE THERE
IS A FACILITY. IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND BECAUSE YOUR
DOCTOR RECOMMENDED IT. AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO DECIDE WELL I CAN'T
AFFORD WHAT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF MY CHILD.
I HAVE TO GO.
BECAUSE MY INSURANCE WILL ONLY
PAY FOR SOMETHING ELSE THAT MAY
HELP ONE OF MY CHILDREN.
BUT IS IT GONNA HELP ALL OF MY
CHILDREN.
WE SHOULD NOT HAVE A MONOPOLY ON
A TREATMENT WHEN A CHILD'S WELL
BEING IS AT STAKE.
AND WE SHOULD DO THE RIGHT THING
AFTER SIX YEAR JOURNEY AND
TAKING MULTIPLE AMENDMENTS AND
WORKING PASSIONATELY WITH LOTS
OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO GET THIS IN THIS POSITION
AGAIN. MEDICALLY NECESSARY
PHYSICIAN PRESCRIBED EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIBEL.
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY MUCH
MISTER PORTANTINO THIS BILL DOES
READ ENJOYED DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I THINK YOU FOR
CONTINUING. A SIX YEAR
CONVERSATION AT THIS POINT.
AND.
BEING GOING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND ALSO YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION GOING
FORWARD SO APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUILAR CURRY IS THERE A SECOND.
THE SECOND BY MISLIM OWN. FIVE
MATT AS MADAM SECRETARY.
WHICH ARE.
THAT MESS UP THAT MISTER I MESS
IT UP ALL THE TIME SO IT WAS
BURKE BUT YOU KNOW IT WAS. THERE
WHEN HE.
YEAH.
I'M SORRY. MISS BURKE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MISS WOODBURN HAS THE
MOTION MISS LIMON HAS A SECOND.
YEAH WELL FUNDED OVER YOU KNOW
THIS.
.
OKAY ALL RIGHT NOW.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MET MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS.
WHAT I WHAT I MAYES?
ACTOR CURRY I THANK YOUR CREE
AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW KNOW BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE. BURKE I CARILLO. REAL AYE
FLORA. FLORA NO LIMON. THE MOON
I MCCARTY.
THIS AREA. THIS AREA AND I
RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO THURMOND.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTES IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
STAT ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PORTANTINO.
SENATOR ROTH'S.
HUGO.
TAKE CARE.
GOT IT.
THIS BILL EXTENDS A SUNSET ON A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
OPERATION OF UP TO TEN SMALL
HOUSE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
THE FACILITIES WILL BE DESIGNED
TO PROVIDE SKILLED NURSING CARE
AND A SMALL HOLD.
NORMALLY STOP TALKING WHEN
YOU'RE WINNING THANK YOU.
SO YOU ARE STOPPING TALKING I
WILL STOP TALKING IN
RESPECTFULLY AS HER HAND I
DON'T.
JEFF ANY WITNESSES
I HAVE VOTE SO SEE DRISCOLL HERE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE IF
YOU HAVE ANY.
THERE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK THAT.
THINK UBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
SEE NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE GULF.
CA NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SAYING THAT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER OFFICE DID DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BREVITY.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MOTION IS OF Y. MISTER BIGELOW
THE SECOND BY MISS THE MOMENT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WAIT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
CARILLO AYE CARILLO AYE FLORA
AYE FLORA AYE LEVEL. LEMOND AYE
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO. BERMAN.
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
THAT IS NINE VOTES OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND WITH THANK YOU SO
MUCH BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS THAT ON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RISK
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE WAITING FOR SENATOR
WIENER.
THIS POINT WE CAN GO BACK
THROUGH.
THE OTHER BILLS UNTIL SENATOR
WIENER ARRIVES.
ALL BILL SO FAR HAVE PASSED IT
WOULD JUST BE ADDING ON.
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE S. THREE
TWENTY MADAM SECRETARY OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOT. SORRY BONTA. BONTA AYE
BURKE.
ROSTER.
FLORA. NO FLORA NO.
SANTIAGO.
SO THAT SITS NINE FOUR AT THIS
POINT THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTED OF.
ITEMS NUMBER.
I'M SORRY.
I DON'T TO EXCUSE ME ITEM WE
JUST THERE WAS HERE. USE.
OBAMA SPOKE.
NOBODY MISTER MAYES NOT VOTING
ON ITEM TO.
AND THEN THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
.
BACKING APPEARANCE I'M ALL OUT
OF SORTS HERE.
HOW CAN SECOND UNDER A COMPOSED
OF ITEMS NUMBER THREE FOUR SEVEN
INANE?
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
BURKE.
FLORA.
FLORA I.
SANTIAGO. BERMAN.
THAT'S IT'S AT TWELVE ZERO AT
THIS POINT WILL.
.
GO TO.
SENATOR WIENER ITEM NUMBER SIX
S. C. R. ONE TEN.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
I THANK YOU FOR OUR HERE BECAUSE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INSIGHT OF
TODAY. UP BECAUSE I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT.
CENTER CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TAT I WANT TO THANK SOME OF
THE REALLY MOAN FOR HER A CO
AUTHORSHIP OF THE RESOLUTION.
AND.
THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES
INTERSECTS CALIFORNIANS HOT AS
AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR STATES
DIVERSITY. OUGHT TO BE
CELEBRATED.
AS OPPOSED TO AN ABERRATION IN
NEED OF CORRECTION.
THE.
RESOLUTION ALSO CALLS ON THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION.
TO.
AVOID.
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY SURGERIES
ON NEWBORNS.
SO THAT CHILDREN CAN.
WHEN THEY'RE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES AND
EXPRESSED THEIR GENDER AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING AYE THAT
DECISION MADE FOR THEM.
WHEN THEY ARE A. B..
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN EVERY TWO
THOUSAND BABIES IS BORN WITH
EXTERNAL SEX CHARACTERISTICS
OTHER NOT.
CONSIDERED.
UNDER TRADITIONAL.
VIEWS AYE AYES TYPICALLY MALE
OR FEMALE.
I SUCH A BABY WOULD BE
CONSIDERED I ENTER SOCKS
AND STANDARD MEDICAL PRACTICE
WOULD BE TO ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
PERFORM NON CONSENSUAL INVENT
SEX ASSIGNMENT SURGERY TO
CONFORM THAT INFANTS BODY. OUGHT
TO A TYPICAL QUOTE UNQUOTE
NOTION OF MASCULINITY OR
FEMININITY.
ASIDE FROM THE OBVIOUS RISK OF A
GETTING ASSIGNED TO THE WRONG
GENDER.
YOU CAN.
SEE A SITUATION WHERE A
DECISION IS MADE FOR A BABY AND
I SURGERY IS. ABA FORM TO SIGN
EITHER MALE OR FEMALE.
SEX CHARACTERISTICS I KNOW NOT
CHILD WHETHER THERE ARE FIVE OR
TEN OR.
WHENEVER THEY EXPRESS THEIR
GENDER.
EXPRESSES THE OPPOSITE GENDER
AND THEN WE HAVE ANY REVERSIBLE.
SURGERY ASIDE FROM THE OBVIOUS
RISK ID'S I SURGERIES CAN LEAD
TO PERMANENT LOST A LOSS OF
SEXUAL SENSATION. STERILIZATION
INCONTINENCE AND A VARIETY OF
SEVERE PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACTS UP
TO AND INCLUDING PTSD.
AND CHRONIC DEPRESSION.
OTHER RUSHED TO PERFORM THE
SURGERY ON INFANTS ARE COMES
FROM A WE BELIEVE A MISGUIDED
NOTION.
THAT INTER SOCKS.
PEOPLE OR INTERSEX BABIES NEED
TO BE QUOTE UNQUOTE NORMALIZED.
AS WELL AS A SENSE THAT THEY
WILL BE BULLIED IF THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO REMAIN PHYSICALLY
ENTER SUCKS
ACCLAIM FOR WHICH THERE IS ZERO
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
ALTHOUGH A SMALL PORTION OF
INTERSEX INFANTS REQUIRE
IMMEDIATE MEDICAL INTERVENTION
FOR A MEDICALLY NECESSARY REASON
FOR EXAMPLE IN ABILITY. AYE TO
URINATE OF THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THESE AYE INFANTS SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO GROW UP
HEALTHY. AND TO DECIDE
FOR-THEMSELVES WHETHER TO HAVE.
THIS IRREVERSIBLE.
SURGERY.
TO PUT IT IN.
EXCUSE ME ON SO THAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT.
PEOPLE'S ABILITY.
TO LIVE THEIR LIVES TO BE WHO
THEY ARE AND NOT TO HAVE THAT
DECISION MADE FOR THEM.
AS A BABY OP BEFORE THEY ARE IN
ANY WAY ABLE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES SO I SEE
ARE ONE TEN IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON RECORD.
AYE IN SUPPORTING THESE CHILDREN
AND SUPPORTING THE INTERSECTS
COMMUNITY.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
SO WITH ME I TODAY I TESTIFY.
IS.
HAND LINDO WHO'S AN ACTIVIST
WITH INTERACT AND AND A INTERSEX
PERSON AND OUGHT TO SUE YOU
TOMORROW MATT US A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN ALSO WINNERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR READER.
GREAT MY NAME IS HAN THE DOLL I
AM INTERACTS COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AS WELL AS A YOUNG
INTERSEX PERSON AN ACTIVIST.
I'M HERE I'VE COME ALL THE WAY
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AS AN
INTERSEX PERSON.
AND I'M HERE BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
MY CONFIDENCE AND MY HAPPINESS
ARE OWED TO THE FACT THAT I HAD
MY OWN DECISION. IN RECEIVING
GENITAL SURGERY.
I MEAN MY CHOICE WHEN I WAS OLD
ENOUGH TO CONSENT AND THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT THING MY PARENTS DID
IT. MY DOCTORS DID IT. I DID.
AND THESE TYPES OF SURGERIES ARE
NOT MEDICALLY NECESSARY. ANY
TYPE OF SURGERY THAT MIGHT
CHANGE APPEARANCE OR SEXUAL
FUNCTION AND WHICH CARRIES VERY
HIGH RISK OF FAILURE.
MUST BE OUR OWN DECISION.
ALL OF US.
DESERVE A CHANCE TO UNDERSTAND
OUR MEDICAL OPTIONS AND WHAT
EFFECTS THEY MIGHT HOUSE.
FOR THE REST OF OUR LIVES.
INTERSEX CHILDREN BORN WITH
GENITAL DIFFERENCES RARELY GET
THAT CHANCE.
THE MOST DRASTIC AND INVASIVE
OPTION IS CHOSEN FOR US BEFORE
WE CAN EVEN SPEAK.
AND I WANNA BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT
ANTI SURGERY. WERE PRO CONSENT
INTERSEX PEOPLE ARE THE ONLY
PEOPLE WHO CAN MAKE THIS
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES.
MEDICINE MUST SERVE THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT.
NOT OTHERS WHO ARE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THEIR DIFFERENCES.
TAKE CONVERSION THERAPY A
PRACTICE THAT'S HARMFUL TO
CHILDREN. AND IS CHOSEN ONLY TO
EASE A PARENT OR AUTHORITIES
SOCIAL DISCOMFORT.
CONVERSION THERAPY HAS BEEN
BANNED IN TWELVE STATES.
UNNECESSARY GENERAL SURGERY ON
INTERSEX KIDS IS PERFORMED FOR
THE SAME REASON APPARENT
AUTHORITIES SOCIAL DISCOMFORT.
PARENTAL UNEASE OR THE MERE
POSSIBILITY OF LOCKER ROOM
BULLYING CANNOT JUSTIFY A
DECISION WITH SUCH HIGH RISK TO
THE PATIENT.
WHAT IF YOU COULD NOT SEX IS AN
ADULT BECAUSE OF A DECISION THAT
SOMEONE MADE HE WAS A BABY?
WHAT IF YOU WERE STERILIZED AS A
BABY AND THAT DECISION WAS MADE
FOR YOU?
THESE ARE STORIES PLEASE PLEASE
LISTEN TO INTERSEX PEOPLE SO
THAT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN TO HAVE
TO HAPPEN TO ANYONE ELSE.
PERHAPS SOME INTERSEX PEOPLE
WILL BE GLAD THAT THEIR PARENTS
MADE A SURGICAL DECISION FOR
THEM AND THAT'S FINE THAT'S
GREAT.
BUT I AM HERE TO SPEAK FOR THE
COUNTLESS OTHERS WERE MUCH LESS
THAN CLOUT WHO SUFFER EVERYDAY.
AND I KNOW MANY INTERSEX
CALIFORNIANS.
WHOSE LIVES WERE COMPROMISED BT
SURGERIES THAT THEY DID NOT.
SO. MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS
OPPOSING THIS RESOLUTION MIGHT
TALK ABOUT HOW TECHNOLOGY HAS
IMPROVED. ABOUT HOW EARLY
SURGERY IS JUSTIFIED IS ONE
OPTION TO OFFER.
THIS IS IRRELEVANT HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS ARE COMMITTED WITH
ALL TYPES AND QUALITIES OF
TOOLS.
THE QUALITY OF THE TOOLS AND
CHANGE THE FACT THAT AN INFANT
WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO CONSENT TO
LIFE ALTERING COSMETIC GENITAL
SURGERY.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY.
THIS IS A HISTORIC FIRST STEP IN
ALIGNMENT WITH INTERNATIONAL
HUMAN RIGHTS GUIDELINES.
BY SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION
YOU STAND WITH ME. THE INTERSEX
COMMUNITY HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
UNITED NATIONS EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA A COUNTLESS OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT STAND FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS.
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI I'M CITY TORMENTAS.
HIM.
I'M A PHYSICIAN LICENSE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M A
PARENT I'M INTERSEX PERSON.
AND I AM URGING YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION BECAUSE THE TIME
HAS COME FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
A STAND.
PHYSICIANS DON'T LIKE TO TAKE
FEEDBACK FROM PEOPLE WHO DON'T
WEAR WHITE COATS.
BUT I AM A PHYSICIAN.
AND I KNOW HOW DESPERATELY IN
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY NEEDS A
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING THAT
PEOPLE LIKE ME ARE NOT BROKEN.
THE CRUX OF THE OPPOSITION AND I
HAVE READ IT.
IS THAT MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS
ARE DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE
ADEQUATELY.
AND THAT ALL OPTIONS NEEDED BE
NEEDS TO BE ON THE TABLE FOR
PARENTS.
I URGE YOU TO RECOGNIZE REALITY
THIS RESOLUTIONS NOT PROHIBIT
SURGERIES IT MERELY ARTICULATES
YOUR DESIRE TO SEE CALIFORNIA
PUT INTO MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY
PROCEDURES. THAT HAVE BEEN
DETERMINED TO BE HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS.
THE PHYSICIANS ADVOCATING FOR
THE SURGERIES IGNORED THAT THE
LARGEST PATIENTS RIGHTS GROUPS.
IN THE WORLD HAVE CALLED FOR
THIS IS FOR SUPPORT AND SWIFT
ACTION TO PROTECT.
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
THIS RESOLUTION INDICATES.
TO THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY AT THE
EXISTENCE OF A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM DOES NOT MAKE
IT ACCEPTABLE TO STERILIZE A
HEALTHY TWO YEAR OLD OR CREATE A
* AND A SIX MONTH OLD.
OR TO REDUCE.
OF A THREE YEAR OLD GIRL.
WE CANNOT ALLOW DOCTORS
CONTINUES PRACTICE BASED ON
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL
PREFERENCES.
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND WITHOUT
ANY RECOGNITION OF THE VALUES OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I NEW PART OF THE REASON YOU'RE
SITTING HERE TODAY IS BECAUSE
YOU CARE ABOUT FORMULA
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN THE
STATE AND VOTER POPULATIONS OF
HEALTH CARE.
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND TO
CELEBRATE THE LOOT THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE LIKE ME AND PEOPLE ICON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION WE THANK SENATOR
WIENER FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
WE ARE AT YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMAN.
AND.
TO CHAIRPERSON AT MISTER WOOD
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA JOHNSON AND I
DROVE UP FROM CARLSBAD DE.
YESTERDAY TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SCR I WON TEN I
THINK.
MISTER WEINER FOR HIS EFFORTS
IN THAT REGARD. AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY I'M A FIFTY YEAR
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ESSENTIALLY BECAUSE OF
BEING INTERSEX.
I DIDN'T MISSION WAS NOT BORN
IN CALIFORNIA CAME FROM ILLINOIS
GREAT STATE OF ILLINOIS.
BUT.
HAVING BEEN BORN INTERSEX.
MY PARENTS MY LOVING PARENTS.
DECIDED THAT IT WAS PROBABLY
THE BEST THING TO DO TO HIM GET
AWAY FROM THE LEERING.
VIEWS AND WORRIES OF FAMILY
MEMBERS AND MAKE A FRESH START
HEARING CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE DID FIFTY YEARS AGO AND.
I'VE BEEN DOING ADVOCACY WORK
FOR. THEM THAT FIFTEEN YEARS
MAYBE THAT TEN YEARS OR SO. AND.
I JUST WANT TO SAY YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR TESTIMONY
FROM PROFESSIONALS WHO.
HAVE ALL KIND OF REASONS TO SAY
THAT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE OPTIONS FOR
SURGERY AND I AM NOT AGAINST ANY
OF MY INTERSEX FRIENDS OR OTHERS
THAT CHOOSE WITH CONSENT.
DO YOU HAVE THOSE SURGERIES DONE
ON THEM THEY SHOULD NOT BE THOSE
DECISION SHOULD NOT BE MADE ON
THEIR BEHALF.
AND SO.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS.
I HOPE THAT THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE PARENTS REALIZE THAT
CHILDREN ARE CHILDREN FOR A
SHORT PART OF TIME WE'RE MOSTLY
GONNA BE ADULTS IT FOR. GRANTED
THAT THE GIFT OF TIME IN AGE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ADULTS LONGER
THAN WE'RE GONNA BE CHILDREN AND
WE HAVE TO FIND THEIR WAY IN
THIS WORLD AND. FIGURE OUT HOW
TO LIVE IN THE BODIES THAT WERE
GIVEN.
AND. MANY OF YOU CAN PROBABLY.
LIVED ATTEST TO THE CHALLENGES
OF BODILY ISSUES AND.
ILLNESSES AND THINGS THAT
INFIRMARIES THAT.
YOU HAVE TO LIVE WITH AND
INTERSEX PEOPLE ARE VERY
RESILIENT WE'RE CAPABLE OF
LIVING IN SOCIETY PRODUCTIVELY.
AND FORMING RELATIONSHIPS AND
HAVING A WONDERFUL LIFE AND.
THAT HAPPENS BEST WHEN WE'RE
LEFT ALONE TO MAKE THAT DECISION
OURSELF SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION
POSITION.
NIKOLAY ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
REVEREND DR PAMELA ANDERSON
MINISTER IN THE PRESBYTERIAN
CHURCH USA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
NO ARTICULATING ARTIST AND
WRITER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CONSTITUENTS STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SHE HAS AREA IN A MEDICAL SCHOOL
STAFF MEMBER AND CONSTITUENTS
SACRAMENTO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
Q..
MARLENA WALTERS CONSTITUENT OF
SUSANVILLE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THREE ONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL
.
AFTER.
CHIEF OF PEDIATRIC UROLOGY AT
YOU SEE YOURSELF. I'VE TAKEN
CARE OF CHILDREN BORN WITH A
TYPICAL GENITALIA AND DISORDERS
OF SEX DEVELOPMENT FOR LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AFTER.
THEIR INTERESTS AND PROTECT THEM
FROM STATE SENATOR WINTERS
PROPOSED RESOLUTION AND US
MISREPRESENTATION OF DISTORTION
OF THE FACTS.
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME I'VE
HEARD STATE SENATOR WIENER MAKE
THE STATEMENT.
THE LAST WAS ON SATURDAY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AT A TOWN HALL
MEETING.
THAT BABY IS BORN WITH A TYPICAL
GENITALIA ARE OUR WISH TO THE
OPERATING ROOM AND ASSIGN
GENDER.
THAT IS SIMPLY.
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
IN FACT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT EACH INDIVIDUAL ASSIGNS
OUR OWN GENDER.
IT'S NOT A SIGN BY DOCTORS IT'S
NOT A SIGN BY NURSES HEALTH CARE
WORKERS PARENTS IS NOT A SIGN BY
SURGERY.
AND IT CERTAINLY SHOULDN'T BE
ASSIGNED BY ANY GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION.
NO SENATOR WIENER BABIES AND
CHILDREN ARE NOT NORMALIZED I
REJECT THE TERM NORMALIZATION
WHICH HAS NO RELEVANCE TO MY
PATIENTS AND I WISH YOU WOULD AS
WELL.
CAN I AM EITHER FOR OR AGAINST
SURGERY.
I AM FOR THE PATIENT AND I'M FOR
ACCESS TO ALL FORMS OF MEDICAL
CARE FOR MY PATIENTS.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
PATIENT ADVOCACY GROUPS THAT I
WORK WITH.
AND WHO HELPED WITH MY PATIENCE.
I'M COR BOARD WITH A TYPICAL
GENITALIA ARE APPALLED.
WITH THE RESOLUTION.
THAT HAS BEEN PUT FORTH AS WELL
AS MULTIPLE OTHER MEDICAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS ALSO INCLUDES PATIENTS
FAMILIES.
AND PATIENTS THEMSELVES FOR
WHICH WE PROVIDE A TEST.
I ASK YOU TO ENDORSE EVIDENCE
BASED MEDICINE SHARE DECISIONS
DECISION MAKING AND RESPECTING
THE RIGHTS OF BOTH.
PARENTS AND PATIENTS.
SENATOR WIENER HOW ABOUT
SPONSORING A BILL TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR PATIENTS BORN IN
YOUR STATE WITHIN GENERAL
TRAINOR HYPERPLASIA. OVERALL
TESTICULAR SYNDROME. GONADAL
DYSGENESIS FIVE ALPHA REDUCTASE
AND GREAT INSENSITIVITY SYNDROME
PERSISTENT ILARION DUCK
SYNDROME.
YES THOSE ARE COMPLICATED
DIAGNOSES THEY INVOLVE COMPLEX
INTERACTIONS WITH THE MEDICAL
FIELD AND FAMILY SUPPORT.
WE'RE HERE TO HELP SENATOR
WIENER TRY TO DEFINE WHAT IS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO HAVE A
DIALOGUE WITH HIS CONSTITUENCY.
PLEASE HELP US IMPROVE AND NOT
LIMIT THEIR CARE. THE FACTS SHOW
THE MEDICAL FACTS THAT NINETY
PERCENT OF PATIENTS WHEN ASKED
AS ADULTS TYPICALLY BEEN
SATISFIED WITH YOUR CARE.
WHO BEEN SATISFIED WITH THEIR
CARE AND WOULD ADVOCATE THE SAME
CARE AGAIN?
STATE SENATOR WIENER I'M YOUR
ADVOCATE. I LIVE IN YOUR
DISTRICT. I VOTED FOR YOU. I'VE
HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU LIKE TO
TASK CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES.
RESPECTFULLY.
DABBLING IN THE COMPLEX CARE OF
CHILDREN AND NOT RESPECTING THE
RIGHTS.
OF PARENTS AND RESTRICTING
ACCESS THE CHILDREN IS NOT FOR
YOU AND NOT FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS RESOLUTION AND I KNOW IT'S
JUST A RESOLUTION CAN HAVE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES TO THE CARE
OF CHILDREN IN RESPECT TO
COVERING. THEIR HEALTHCARE.
IN CALIFORNIA UNITED STATES AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD THEREFORE
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED.
GENTLEMEN I'M ERIN SPITS
METEOROLOGIST ON THE LEAD
DELEGATE TO THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HOUSE OF DELEGATES.
FOR THE AMERICAN UROLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION.
AND ALTHOUGH THE INTENTION OF
THIS RESOLUTION IS TO SUPPORT
THE INDIVIDUAL'S ABILITY TO
PRESERVE AND AFFIRM THEIR
GENDER.
UNFORTUNATELY WILL RESULT IN THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OUTCOME.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO DRAFT THIS
REVENUE RESOLUTION IS INCOMPLETE
OUTDATED OR INCORRECT.
CONGENITAL ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA
REPRESENTS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE CHILDREN CURRENTLY RECEIVING
SURGICAL CARE.
IT IS NOT CONSIDERED INTERSEX
BUT IT IS UNFORTUNATELY SUBJECT
TO THIS RESOLUTION.
IT'S A CONDITION THAT CAUSES TOO
MUCH TESTOSTERONE TO BE PRODUCED
BY THE ADRENAL GLAND AND INFANT
GIRLS WHICH CAN RESULT IN THEIR
EXTERNAL GENITALS LOOKING VERY
MUCH LIKE A* AND*.
BUT DESPITE THE EXCESS
TESTOSTERONE THEY ARE GIRLS AND
AS THEY GROW UP THEY IDENTIFY AS
GIRLS.
THEY'RE GENETICALLY FEMALE AND
AS ADULTS THEY IDENTIFIES WOMEN
IN WHEN THEY ARE SURVEYS THEY
STATE THAT THEY ARE GLAD THAT
THEY WERE PROVIDED SURGERY THAT
ALLOW THEM TO GROW UP AS GIRLS.
YOU HAVE LETTERS FROM THESE
GIRLS AND FAMILIES BEFORE YOU
NOW.
THIS RESOLUTION WOULD FORCE
THESE GIRLS TO GROW UP WITH THE
PHYSICAL APPEARANCE AND THAT'S
IT DOES NOT MATCH THEIR IDENTITY
WHICH HAS THE POTENTIAL TO CAUSE
THEM A LIFETIME OF.
PSYCHOLOGICAL DISTRESS AND BODY
DYSPHORIA.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
DEFINES HEALTH AS QUOTE A STATE
OF COMPLETE PHYSICAL MENTAL AND
SOCIAL WELL BEING AND NOT MERELY
THE ABSENCE ORDERED OF DISEASE
OR INFIRMITY UNQUOTE SO THE
SURGERIES ARE INDEED MEDICALLY
NECESSARY.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL TURMOIL ENTERED BY
THOSE ADULT PATIENTS WHAT A LESS
THAN OPTIMAL OUTCOME FROM PAST
SURGERY AND HAVE THE US BROUGHT
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD. BUT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS PAIN SHOULD
NOT BE THE REASON TO DEPRIVE
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING AN ENLIGHTENED
AND SCIENTIFIC APPROACH. LED US
TO WE APPROACH ALL THESE
CHILDREN WITH GREAT CARE
INVOLVING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
MOTHER FATHER PEDIATRICIAN AND
CHRONOLOGIES GENETICIST ETHICIST
PSYCHOLOGIST. ADVOCATES AND
SURGEON ALL COME TOGETHER TO
MAKE THESE DECISIONS WITH GREAT
DELIBERATION AND TRANSPARENCY
ONE INDIVIDUAL AT A TIME THESE
ARE NOT SNAP JUDGMENTS.
WE SEEK AN AMENDMENT TO ALLOW
CHILDREN WITH NOBLE GENDER
IDENTITY SUCH AS CONGENITAL
ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA ACCESS TO
SURGERY. SO THEY MAY LIVE A LIFE
THAT IS AFFIRMING THEIR GENDER.
THANK YOU.
ACCURATE MUCH.
OTHER OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO
YOUR NAME IN OREGON.
DR LINDA SHORTLY.
PAST CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
UROLOGY AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
PEDIATRIC UROLOGIST. NINETEEN
SIXTY CENTS A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT THANK YOU.
DOCTOR ROGER DE FILIPPO CHIEF OF
PEDIATRIC UROLOGISTS HOLDS
HOSPITAL SANDERS WAY OPPOSE THIS
RESOLUTION.
SERWIS BITS OF LAGUNA BEACH I
OPPOSE THIS UP THIS.
S..
ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU. I AND I I THINK YOU
AS SENATOR WIENER FOR
AS FAR AS YOU AND I HAD OUR.
THE EARLIER IN THE YEAR TO TALK
ABOUT THIS INCOME PART IT IT
REALLY WAS TO HAVE A STATEMENT
MADE ABOUT.
I AFFIRMING GENDER AND ALLOWING
IT TO BE.
A FIRM THAT GENDER FOR
THEMSELVES
AND THERE WAS A QUESTION RAISED
BY THE UP OR A COMMENT MADE BY
THE OPPOSITE.
IT WOULD AND THIS RESOLUTION A
RESOLUTION WITH SEVERELY HARM.
FOLKS CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
THAT WHAT YOU MEAN BY
RESOLUTIONS
NEARLY HARMING FOLKS.
WELL THIS RESOLUTION. CAN PUT A
CHILLING EFFECT ON HOSPITALS AND
DOCTORS WILLINGNESS
TO PROVIDE THE HOUSE SALARIES
IT'S A RESOLUTIONS OUR HOUSE SO.
WE RECEIVED EARLIER OUR SOCIETY.
A LETTER FROM LAMBDA LEGAL THAT
HAD A THREATENING TONE ABOUT
LAWSUITS BEING BROUGHT AGAINST.
PROVIDERS OF SURGERY.
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS AND I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT A RESOLUTION
THAT STATES THAT THE SURGERY
SHOULD NOT BE DONE ON. INFANTS
AND YOUNG CHILDREN.
WAIT.
GIVE FIREPOWER TOSUCH LAWSUITS
IF THEY WERE PROCEED TO YOU
IMAGINE YOU'RE NOT SURE YOU'LL
HAVE EVIDENCE.
YOU'RE JUST IMAGINING THAT THIS
WOULD.
I'M QUITE CERTAIN THAT IT WOULD
GIVE IT FIREPOWER.
SOARING AND I HAVE.
IS.
WE HAVE NOT CAUCUS TO DEFINE
WHAT MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A DISCUSSION.
IT'S LOOKED UP FROM MANY BIT A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE SINCE
PERSPECTIVE THAT I LOOK AT IT
AND NOT THE PARENTS LOOK AT IT
HIS THE SURGERY THAT'S PERFORMED
IS NOT.
EXCUSE MY BLUNT TERMINOLOGY
REMOVING A* THAT'S TO SIMPLY
NOT DONE.
SURGERY THAT WERE PERFORMING
NINE PERCENT OF THE TIME IS A
GIRL. WITH CHROMOSOMES THAT ARE
A GIRL WITH OVARIES WITH FUTURE
FERTILITY POTENTIAL WHO HAS A
NORMAL* THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
OUT AT THE SKIN SOURCE COLOR
YOUR GENERAL SINUS REPAIR.
ANY EFFORT.
WITH THE RESOLUTION. WHICH.
IS A RESOLUTION.
WELL INFLUENCE INSURANCE
COMPANIES ABOUT COVERAGE.
WHICH HAS A DIRECT IMPLICATION
ON ACCESS TO OUR PATIENTS FOR
ALL FORMS OF MEDICAL CARE.
SO WHAT YOU SAID IT WAS THAT A
CONVERSATION
HAPPEN I'M A MONTH WHERE MEDICAL
EXPERTS
NO NO NO CONVERSATION HASN'T
HAPPENED AMONG.
MYSELF.
AND THE PEOPLE HERE AND ALL THE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE AGAINST
THIS RESOLUTION AND STATE
SENATOR LEADERS OFFICE IN SPITE
OF ME AGGRESSIVELY SOME SIDE IN
HIS DISTRICT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ON WHAT'S MEDICALLY
NECESSARY.
RIGHT AND SO WRITER RECYCLED
BACK TO THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
RESOLUTION
IS A STATEMENT.
MONTH AND I'M NOT SURE THAT I
SEE THE ADVANCE I VERY MUCH
VALUE YOUR EX.
IT'S YOU HAVE AN EXPERTISE THAT
FOR EXAMPLE I DON'T.
BUT A SEE ALSO WHAT HAPPENS
WITH RESOLUTIONS AND HOW
RESOLUTIONS ARE USED
AND I AND I FEEL THAT.
WHAT'S BEING BROUGHT FORWARD TO
US TODAY IS IN A PER AN
AFFIRMATION.
I'M AN AFFIRMATION OF.
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE I AM ABLE TO AFFIRM THEIR
OWN AT A GENDER I THINK THAT
THIS WILL. MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY
THAT WILL CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
YOU WILL ALL BE PART OF THOSE
CRIMES
STATIONS ON AND AT THIS TIME AS
A RESOLUTION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. AND IT TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO IT I THINK THAT THIS
IS NOT AN ISSUE THAT IS NEW TO
US.
IN CALIFORNIA AS A MATTER OF
FACT AND THERE'S BEEN A STRONG
MOVEMENT AND FOR DECADES AND SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD I UNDERSTAND. THAT AS
SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN DONE
ON BEFORE IT CAN RAISE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ON A CAN RAISE A LOT
OF THE.
ISSUES FOR S. AND I THINK THAT
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY YOU ARE
HEARING YOU ARE RAISING THOSE
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
BUT AT AGAIN AS A STATEMENT.
OF SOMEWHAT WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO AFFIRM
THEIR GENDER AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL SUPPORT THAT THE
BILL. AND.
I THAT I'M OF THE BILL.
THIS THE BILL THE RESOLUTION.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TO RAISE.
BUT SENATOR WIENER DONE BUT YOU
KNOW I'VE GOT A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPECT FOR YOU IN FACT SO AS I.
.
THOSE PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY AND THAT AFTER HEARING
NEUROLOGISTS TIME.
I'M NOT SURE ANY LONGER I'M
FASCINATED ACTUALLY BY THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE.
THE IT'S GOT ETHICAL
IMPLICATIONS PHILOSOPHICAL
IMPLICATIONS
AB RELIGIOUS IMPLICATIONS
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPLICATIONS I
MEAN IT IS AN EXCEPTIONALLY
COMPLEX.
A QUESTION
AND I FEEL LIKE I AM.
NOT ABLE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THIS DECISION I GUESS THE ONE
QUESTION IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A RESOLUTION.
VERSES A PIECE OF
OF LEGISLATION THAT WOULD BE BUT
THAT HAVE A FOR FORCE AND EFFECT
OF LAW WHITE Y. RESOLUTION AND
NOTS.
AND NOT MOVE DOWN AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ROUTE LACKEY SURE
ON.
AND FIRST OF ALL.
WELL. THERE HAS BEEN
LEGISLATION OTHER STATES IN THE
BOTTOM THAT I SEE PASSED OUT OF
ONE OF THE. LEGISLATION TO BAN.
THAT THE SURGERY.
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY THE PAST
ONE OF THE HOUSES AND THEN A
FAILED IN THE SECOND HOUSE. IN
TEXAS IT WAS INTRODUCED SO IT
HAS BEEN INTRODUCED TO AND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE.
IS ORGANIZING AROUND THAT
BECAUSE THESE ARE PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND THEY WANNA.
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND SO.
WE WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL TO DO RESOLUTION.
RAISE THE ISSUE.
START A DIALOGUE.
ABOUT IT.
EDUCATE.
AND ANNOUNCED THAT'S WHY WE'RE
DOING A RESOLUTION AND THAT I
THINK IT HAS BEEN HELPFUL.
I WANTED TO SAY.
.
TERMS MEDICAL PROFESSION.
I COULD'VE GOTTEN A BUNCH OF
DOCTORS
AND THAT STUDENTS TO COME HERE
TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WHICH WAS INITIALLY
OPPOSED HAS REMOVED ITS
OPPOSITION WE. WE DID IT IS NOT
ACCURATE TO SAY THAT WE'VE NOT
BEEN SPEAKING TO THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION WE'VE. ENGAGED
EXTENSIVELY AND CMI HAS REMOVED
ITS OPPOSITION AND AS A RESULT
OF SOME AMENDMENTS.
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THEIR LOCAL
MEDICAL SOCIETIES THAT AND AT
THE OUTSET WANTED TO.
DORIS THE BILL.
BUT THEY WANT ONE CM A
TEMPORARILY CAME ON OPPOSITION
THEY FELT THEY WERE PRECLUDED
FROM.
FROM DOING THAT THERE IS
DEFINITELY A ROBUST DEBATE
OCCURRING WITHIN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IN TIME AND REALIZE THAT SOME OF
THE WAYS WE'VE DONE THINGS IN
THE PAST. ARE NOT NECESSARILY
THE RIGHT WAY TO DO THAT.
AYE AND YOU'RE ALWAYS THIS ARE
DEFINITELY VERY OPPOSED.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT OUT BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT NECESSARILY
REFLUX
THE ENTIRE MEDICAL.
PROFESSION AND I WANT TO JUST
REALLY STRESS.
WHEN THE.
WHEN THE DOCTOR TALKED ABOUT
ALL OF THIS IS NOT A SNOB
JUDGMENT IT'S NOT BROTHERS
WHISKEY. BABIES FROM THE
BIRTHING ROOM TO DO THE SURGERY.
AND THERE'S ALL THESE PEOPLE
INVOLVED THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THIS DECISION.
BECAUSE ONE PERSON THAT WAS LEFT
OUT OF THAT DECISION.
A PERSON WHOSE LIFE WILL BE
PERMANENTLY IRREVERSIBLY
IMPACTED.
BY ABOUT SURGERY.
THAT BECAUSE A PERSON IS A BABY
OR AN INFANT AND IS A LEASE FOR
AWHILE MIGHT ABLE TO EXPRESS.
THEIR GENDER TAKES
TIME
THE CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. AND SO ALL OVER ASKING IS
FOR.
TO GIVE THAT SPACE
SO THAT THAT CHILD CAN MAKE A
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES. I
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE ONCE THEY TURN
EIGHTEEN. WE KNOW THEIR CHILDREN
NOW HAVE THESE FIVE SIX A TECH
WHO WERE VERY STRONGLY AFFIRMING
THEIR GENDER.
AND THEN THEIR PARENTS ARE
BEING RESPECTFUL AND WORKING
WITH THEM AND GIVING THEM THE
MEDICAL CARE. THEY NEED OR DON'T
AND NOT GIVING THE MEDICAL CARE
THEY DON'T NEED
US THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS.
AND IF I CAN.
MISTER CHAIR OF.
FROM THE. FACT THAT CMA IS NOT
OPPOSE THIS ANY LONGER ABOUT THE
UROLOGIST AND I APOLOGIZE OF A
BEEN HERE FOR FOUR YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE. AND.
THERE WAS A TERM I LEARNED
WHILE IN COLLEGE RENT SEE.
AND SO WE HAVE LOTS OF GROUPS
THAT COME IN ARE POSTED THINGS
ON BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
ECONOMIC ADVANTAGE OR
DISADVANTAGE
THEY SUPPORTER OPPOSE THINGS
BASED UPON THAT. AND SO I GUESS
THE IN LISTENED YOUR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS.
.
WHY HAS IT WHAT WHY IS THIS A
QUESTION THAT YOU AS AN
ORGANIZATION HAVE IT FIGURED OUT
AND MAYBE EVEN PROPOSED?
SOME.
SOME SOME GUIDELINES AT TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT AND WHAT WOULD
IT TAKE FOR YOU GUYS TO BE ABLE
TO.
TO SUPPORT OF. A RESOLUTION OR
EVEN SOME LEGISLATION A TO THIS.
IF YOU ARE. THESE ARE NOT GENDER
REAFFIRMING SURGERIES ARE TRYING
TO MAKE THAT POINT.
THESE ARE CHILDREN WHO HAVE
CONGENITAL ANOMALIES LIKE A
CLEFT PALATE.
MY WOMAN INTEREST STILL.
A CARDIAC DEFECT THAT'S FIXED.
RESTORING NORMAL ANATOMY.
THIS IS TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN.
LET ME ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT OUR POSITION AND
CONSENSUS.
.
SENATOR WIENER UNFORTUNATELY MAY
HAVE BEEN GIVEN BAD INFORMATION
BUT MIS CHARACTERIZED WHAT THE
LEVEL OF CONSENSUS IS AND ALSO.
WHAT THE DIALOGUE AT THAT LEVEL
THE CMA HAS BEEN?
IN FACT.
THIS YEAR MAY OPPOSED THE
RESOLUTION THAT WAS INTRODUCED
INTO THE CMA THAT WAS VERY
SIMILAR IN LANGUAGE. AS OPPOSED
TO ITS POSITION ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IT'S PENDING
AGREEMENT ON AMENDMENTS THAT.
ARE STILL. IN PROCESS.
SO TO MISS CHARACTERIZATION TO
THINK OF THE CMA IS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION FURTHERMORE
WE DID CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS.
FROM PEDIATRICS TO
ENDOCRINOLOGIST PSYCHOLOGISTS
PSYCHIATRISTS.
AND.
PEDIATRIC SURGEONS AS WELL AS.
ACTIVIST KENNY GENERAL. THOUGH.
WHY DON'T WE HAVE ANY BUT WAS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION?
FROM THOSE FROM THOSE GROUPS
ONLY OPPOSITION I SEE IS FROM.
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION FOR
CLINICAL UROLOGISTS IN THE
AMERICAN UROLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
HOW COME THOSE OTHERS.
HAVEN'T MY HAVE BEEN DEPOSED.
ARE WE ACTUALLY HAVE PROVIDED A
CONSENSUS STATEMENT.
BUT IT MAY THAT IT'S NOT AND
NOT PACKET THIS IS A PACKET I
PUT TOGETHER AS AN ADDENDUM.
BUT THE CONSENSUS OF THESE
NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS ON
CONFERENCE CALLS THAT INCLUDED
INTERACT MEDICALSTUDENT
ASSOCIATION IN THE GAY AND
LESBIAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS ALL
STAKEHOLDERS WE NEWARK.
INVOLVED.
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS EXCEPT FOR
INTERACT MEDICAL STUDENT SECTION
AND BEGAN MEDICAL AS WE
DISSOCIATION CAME WITH A
CONSENSUS. THAT THERE SHOULD NOT
BE A MORATORIUM ON SURGERY FOR
INFANTS AND CHILDREN BECAUSE ARE
INDEED PER CASES WHERE THERE WAS
GOOD PROVIDED. AND THAT WAS IN
FACT THE CONSENSUS AND TO HAVE
GUIDELINES IN A SITUATION THAT
REQUIRES SUCH A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY INDIVIDUALIZED
APPROACH. EVEN IS PROBLEMATIC
BUT WHAT WE DO DO IS TAKE A VERY
CAREFUL MULTI DISCIPLINARY
APPROACH AND WE MOVE WITH GREAT
CARE.
MISTER JORDAN FIVE I I WANT TO
JUST CRIED I'D MADE US LIKE A
STATEMENT PROBLEMS CLIMATE CMA
OF WERE WORKING WITH THEM ON THE
MEN WERE RIGHT AT THE AND THEY
TOLD US THAT THEY. WILL REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION ONCE WE.
FINALIZE OUT AND PUT IT ACROSS
OTHER DID NOT SUBMIT OPPOSE
LATER THIS COMMITTEES ARE NOT
HERE I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THEY'RE NOT YEAH I'M ONLY GONNA
BUT THEY'VE INDICATED. THAT
WILL.
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
CARILLO.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER FOR
BRINGING THIS TO THIS RESOLUTION
TO OUR ATTENTION.
JUST TIME.
IN HEARING THE TESTIMONY.
THERE'S BEEN WORDS LIKE NORMAL
BEING USED.
AND THAT'S PROBLEMATIC.
THIS IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND WHAT WE CAN'T WHAT WE HAVE
CONSIDERED NORMAL IN THE PAST.
IN TERMS OF.
WHAT'S BEING DESCRIBED TODAY IS
NOT THE APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE
THAT WE USE TO ADDRESS.
THE COMMUNITY THAT IS IN OUR SEX
OR THE LGBT COMMUNITY WHICH HAS.
CONTINUOUSLY FOUGHT FOR THEIR
VERY MERRICK'S THIS.
AND SO THIS AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
IS A CELEBRATION OF PEOPLE
IT'S A RESOLUTION TO CELEBRATE
PEOPLE THAT ARE INTERSEX.
AND THAT YOU SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
RIGHT TO LIVE YOUR LIFE THE WAY
YOU WANT TO LIVE YOUR LIFE AND
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL OF
US TO BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE
ALREADY NORMAL TO.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT YOU NEED
TO CHANGE AND THERE IS NOTHING
THAT.
SOMEONE ELSE CAN TELL YOU ABOUT
WHO YOU ARE.
AND IT'S CHALLENGING TWO PERCENT
AND SHARE YOUR STORY PEOPLE THAT
MAY NOT BE AS FAMILIAR.
WITH THE ISSUE
SO I I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION AND I HOPE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND OTHERS CAN BEGIN
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A.
WHOLE OTHER WORLD IN
CONVERSATION ABOUT GENDER AND
SEXUALITY THAT IT'S MUCH MORE
FLUID.
THEN THE NORMAL CONVERSATION
THAT THAT HAS BEEN HAD IN THE
PAST
THANK YOU.
THE GIVES MR THIS AREA MY
APOLOGIES I SKIPPED ADDED ME TO
DO THAT BECAUSE I DON'T. THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
DERECHOS EVENTUALLY GONNA GET.
EVERYONE.
.
SENATOR I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
BECAUSE I'VE STRUGGLED WITH IT
AND AND USUALLY YOUR BILLS AND
THIS COMMITTEE I'M.
I'M ON BOARD.
THIS IS A RESOLUTION SALT
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO.
TAKE SUCH AN ISSUE LIKE THIS
INTO HAND. WHEN THERE'S VERY
LITTLE DATA AVAILABLE.
AND I'VE CONTACT WE'VE.
I THINK AT THE STAFF LEVEL CUT
COMMUNICATED AND ASK FOR THE
DATA.
I TRY TO LOOK FOR IT IN OTHER
PLACES JUST NOW. FOR THE FIRST
TIME I HEARD FROM NOT MISTAKEN
NINE PERCENT OF SURGERIES FEW
ONE ELABORATE ON THAT IT BE
INTERESTED BUT BEFORE YOU DO.
AND THEN THE OTHER ISSUE WAS.
IF IF IF THIS HAD. IF THIS BILL
HAD BEEN ADVANCED IN NEVADA
WHAT.
DATA WAS USED THEIR TO ADVANCE
THE ISSUE.
I AND I.
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE AND
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO MOVE
FORWARD?
?
GIVEN THE SENSITIVITIES OF THE
ISSUE THERE MAY BE PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DON'T ADDRESS
THIS
ISSUE WITH.
THE CARE AND THOUGHTFULNESS AND.
MAYBE THE UNIFORMITY THAT IT
NEEDS
SO.
THERE NEEDS TO BE GREATER
AWARENESS THROUGH THIS MEASURE I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND APPRECIATE
THAT HARD VERY MUCH BUT.
WHEN YOU GET INTO THE SCIENCE
PORTION OF IT I'M JUST
WONDERING.
THERE ISN'T ENOUGH DATA TO BE.
.
REALLY UPHOLDING THIS SO IF THIS
WAS A BILL I'D BE STRUGGLING I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY.
SO IF THERE IS SOME DATA THAT
YOU CAN SHED SOME LIGHT ON AND
OFF FOR A I'D. LIKE TO HEAR FROM
BOTH SIDES.
CAN I SPEAK TO THAT.
YOU KNOW OH WHEREIN I BOTH SPOKE
TO THE CENSUS GO A HUMAN RIGHTS
COMMITTEE BACK IN.
AS THE NINETIES EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS.
AND WE BOTH ARE SAYING THE SAME
THING AT THAT POINT.
BUT THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS NOW
IT WAS TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THERE
STILL IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
SURGERIES ACTUALLY. HAVE ANY
GOOD OUTCOMES AND THERE'S PLENTY
OF EVIDENCE THAT THEY HAVE VERY
BAD OUTCOMES AND CATASTROPHIC
OUTCOMES.
REFER YOU TO THE LETTER THAT WAS
SENT TO ALL OF YOU FROM A DOCTOR
EILEEN WONKY SUMMARIZES
A LOT OF.
LARRY'S POINTS ABOUT.
WHAT SURGERIES HE'S DOING AND
WHAT THE PERCENTAGES ARE?
I ALSO LIKE TO MENTION TO YOU
THAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION DOES FUNNY
SURGERIES TO BE AGAINST WHAT
THEY CONSIDER PERSONAL AUTONOMY.
AND THEIR DANCING SURGERIES AS
WELL.
THINKING.
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
ALTHOUGH THIS IS JUST A
RESOLUTION THE WHEREAS IS THAT
IT IS BASED UPON GROSSLY
MISREPRESENT THE SCIENCE AND THE
FACTS.
SO EVEN THOUGH THE INTENTIONS
ARE GOOD. TO COME OUT OF THE
GATE. WITH A FOUNDATION FOR
POSSIBLE LEGISLATION THE FUTURE
BASED ON SO MANY GROSS
MISREPRESENTATIONS AND.
INCORRECT STATEMENTS I THINK
WOULD BE HARMFUL TO. WHAT COULD
OTHERWISE BE A VERY UPLIFTING
AND AND HELPFUL CONVERSATION IN
THE FUTURE?
OF THE PATIENTS TO UNDERGO
SURGERY NINETY PERCENT OF THEM
ARE CONGENITAL ADRENAL
HYPERPLASIA PATIENTS WHICH ARE
GIRLS WHOSE GENDER IDENTITY IS
FEMALE. BUT HIS GENITALS ARE
OVER STIMULATED BY TESTOSTERONE
AND LOOK LIKE MALE GENITALS.
THESE GIRLS ARE NOT FORCED TO.
IDENTIFIES GROWTH BY THE
COMMUNITY OR THEIR SOCIETY THIS
IS THEIR BRAIN SEX THIS IS THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY. AND IT'S A
MATTER OF WHEN THEY'RE ALLOWED
TO HAVE THAT AFFIRMING SURGERY
WE'VE BECOME MUCH MORE
ENLIGHTENED IN ALLOWING PEOPLE
WITH GENDER DYSPHORIA TO HAVE
GENDER AFFIRMING SURGERY AT
YOUNGER AND YOUNGER AGES.
WE'RE NOW MOVING PAST ADULTHOOD
AND ADOLESCENCE AND EVEN PRE
ADOLESCENTS ALLOWING. THESE
PEOPLE TO TRANSITION WITH
HORMONAL THERAPY AND THEN
EVENTUALLY SURGERY WHY WOULD WE
DO THE EXACT OPPOSITE WITH THIS
POPULATION OF GIRLS AND PREVENT
THEM FROM AFFIRMING THEIR
CHATTER. UNTIL THEY'RE AT OLDER
AGES BECAUSE WHO KNOWS WHAT THE
AGE. THE LOWER LIMIT AT THE AGE
OF OUR ABILITY WILL BE AND WHO
KNOWS WHEN ONE'S IDENTIFICATION
OF THEIR GENITALIA STARTS TO.
RATIFY WITH THEIR SELF
IDENTIFICATION IN THE OTHER WAYS
IN WHICH THEY PERCEIVE THE WORLD
AROUND THEM. WHEN IS THE
APPROPRIATE AGE TO FINALLY ALLOW
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THEIR IDENTITY AND AGAIN IT'S
NINETY PERCENT OF THE PATIENTS
WHO UNDERGO SURGERY OR CAN THIS
CATEGORIZATION.
I'D I JUST WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK THROUGH POP BETTER
THE SCIENTIFIC MEDICAL.
DATABASE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF STUDIES
WERE WOMEN WHO HAVE CONGENITAL
HYPERPLASIA.
A FORM OF DST WHICH THEY DON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE.
YEAH BECAUSE THEY REFERRED US TO
BE CALL NORMAL PEOPLE WHICH THEY
ARE. ARE HAPPY WITH THEIR
OUTCOMES WHEN THEY HAD SURGERY
OF CHILDHOOD AND MORE AND WHEN
ASKED WHETHER THEY WOULD PREFER
TO HAVE THE SURGERY.
IF THEY. WEREN'T GIVEN THE
SURGERY THEY DEFINITELY HAVE
PREFERRED TO HAVE THE SURGERY AS
BABIES.
SO OF THE OUTCOMES THERE THE
LETTER SHE WAS THERE. IN THIS
GROUP OF PATIENTS WE HAVE
EXCELLENT LONG TERM DATA IN SOME
OF THE OTHER REFER PATIENTS.
WE DON'T WERE GATHERING BUT THIS
IS THE. PATIENT GROUP THAT WE
SEE MOST OFTEN.
SHERIFF YOU KNOW I JUST HAVE
BEEN FOLLOWED BY A. I'M MISSING
SOMETHING SO IT SAYS BETWEEN.
ONE TO TWO PERCENT OF
INDIVIDUALS ARE BORN WITH
VARIATIONS IN THEIR PHYSICAL.
SEX CHARACTERISTICS.
OF THE ONE TO TWO PERCENT WHAT
PERCENTAGE AND GOING THROUGH
SURGERY.
AND.
LEAVE MY ESTIMATE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S IN THE RESOLUTION AS IT
SPITS WAY LESS THAN ONE PERCENT
ARE BORN WITH A TYPICAL
GENITALIA.
SO I THINK THAT'S A
MISREPRESENTATION OF THE ACTUAL
FACTS.
THE NUMBER OF SURGERIES ARE DONE
IN THIS COUNTRY. IN MY OPINION
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
POTENTIALLY CONTROVERSIAL OR
LESS THAN ONE HUNDRED.
IN THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
SPUR.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU AND I DON'T I'M.
IS YOUR INTENT TO MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR INFANTS WHO ARE
GENETICALLY FEMALE. WHO ARE JUST
HAVING A EUROPE UROLOGICAL ISSUE
FOR THEM TO GET CORRECTIVE
SURGERY IS THAT YOUR AND TEN OR
NINE?
BOB.
HER PARENTS HAD IS NOT TO.
FOR ONCE SURGERY IS MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY.
TO.
TO TO THE FOR SO.
ALWAYS GONNA BE A SPECTRUM RAIN
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S SECURE
SOLVING ANYONE.
IT'S GOING TO SAY THAT IF YOU
HAVE.
IT FOR IF WE LOOK AT ONE END OF
THE SPECTRUM A MINOR.
YOU KNOW ISSUE THAT NO LONGER
SURGERY GUY AND WHEN WE GET THE
COMPARISON THE CLEFT PALATE
WHICH. YOU KNOW IT'S AN ALTAR
SORT IT OUT GENDER AND AND THERE
ARE SOME PROCEDURES THAT IMPACT.
THE ASSIGNMENT. AGENDA PHYSICAL
ASSIGNMENT OF GENDER AND SOME
THAT DON'T
AND YOU GET IF THERE WERE EFFORT
ON THIS AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT
WHAT WE HAVE NINE.
GOTTEN THERE.
THAT OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO YOU
KNOW THAT YOU GOT THIS GOES YES
AND PUT BECAUSE THIS IS A MORE
GENERAL RESOLUTION.
TO PUT US ON THE RECORD SO TO BE
SUPER CLEAR I COMPLETELY SUPPORT
YOU I I DO NOT THINK IT ANY TIME
THIS IS A RESOLUTION IS A
RESOLUTION WITHIN A.
CONVERSATION THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
I KNOW THIS SENATOR I DO NOT
BELIEVE FOR ONE MINUTE I MEAN I
HAVE A YOUNG DAUGHTER I DO NOT
BELIEVE FOR ONE MINUTE THAT HE
WOULD EVER WANT.
USE OF SOME SORT OF SIMPLE
SURGERY TO HELP WITH YOUR OLOGY
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT TO EVER
BE.
GIVEN TO EACH CHILD I THINK WHAT
I THINK I THINK YOU ARE VERY
CLEAR ON YOUR INTENT HERE I
THINK THE OPPOSITION IS GOING A
LITTLE TOO FAR IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY ARE SAYING THAT YOU WERE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING. THAT I
JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE CLAIMING
COMPLETE SUPPORT.
PEOPLE NEED TIME TO KNOW WHO
THEY ARE AND YES.
AS AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID WE
SHOULD LOVE PEOPLE FOR WHO THEY
ARE AND AS WELL EVERYBODY WANTS
AND
S. WORLD.
SO.
I DON'T THINK THAT I THINK WE'RE
COMPARING APPLES TO ORANGES HERE
AND WITHOUT I JUST WOULD.
I JUST I AM I AM VERY GLAD THAT
YOU'RE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
AND IF IT IS EVER A BILL I HAVE
NO DOUBT THAT YOU WILL DEAL WITH
THE SPACE
SOME OF THE ISSUES AND THE GRAY
AREAS THAT NEED.
ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER.
.
BUT LET'S CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THIS WAS SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
FOR THE CONVERSATION I THINK.
HIS.
AS YOU CAN TELL BY THE
CONVERSATION IT'S IT'S.
YOU EDUCATED US ABOUT ABOUT FOR
SOME WHO ABOUT ISSUES THAT THEY
MAY HAVE NEVER CONSIDERED AND.
I APPRECATE DOT I ALSO AGREE
THAT A A RESOLUTION IS A
RESOLUTION IT IS NOT A LEGAL
BINDING.
DOCUMENT THAT FORCES ANYBODY TO
DO ANYTHING ON BUT I THINK IT'S
A REALLY VALUABLE PART OF THE
OF.
CONTINUING TO BRING A
CONVERSATION FORWARDED I AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE THAT
SHOULD YOU EVER BRING A BILL FOR
IT WILL BE EXTREMELY WELL
THOUGHT OUT. IT WILL BE WELL
RESEARCHED AND YOU WILL ENGAGE
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS I'D I KNOW
THAT FROM HAVING WORKED WITH YOU
SO. I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING I APPRECIATE THIS OF THIS
RESOLUTION IT ENJOYS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION WHEN ALLOWED TO
ASK THE SECRETARY TO.
.
CALL THE ROLL THAT THE RIGHT
THERE THEM MOTION WE HAVE FROM.
IS FROM.
MISSED LOW MOAN THE SECOND IS
FROM.
MISTER BONTA AND THE MOTION IS
THE ADOPTED TO JUDICIARY.
DOUBLE REFERRED IN BOTH HOUSES
RESOLUTION. STUDY OF DIALOGUE
AND.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WAIT I THOUGHT
WHEN I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
IT LOW ENOUGH VOTING BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON I'M MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN. IN THIS AREA AND I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE BERMAN.
WALDRON.
RESOLUTION AS EIGHT BITS AT SO
IT'S OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND.
HAVE A.
GOOD CONVERSATION WITH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU TO
WITNESSES AS WELL THINK
BUT THE POLICY.
OKAY THAT.
WE HAVE NOW GONE THROUGH ALL THE
BILLS AND WE WILL GO OF MEMBERS
WHO HAVE NOT VOTED.
WHO INTEND TO VOTE?
PLEASE COME BACK TO THE CHAMBER
SO WE CAN DO THAT.
WILL START AT THE TOP AND WILL
OF ALL THE ALL THE BILLS HAVE
BEEN.
ALL ALL THE BILLS HAVE BEEN
VOTED OUT OF COMMITTEES OF THIS
IT THESE ARE ALL.
OPPORTUNIST ADD ON TO VOTE SO
NO SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB THREE TWENTY.
BURKE.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
SO THAT IS TEN TO FOUR.
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. THREE
NINETY NINE OVER THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCCARTY.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE BERMAN.
THAT'S TENDED.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR INCLUDES
ITEMS NUMBER THREE S. S. S. B.
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT ITEMS OVER FOR
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTEEN I REMEMBER
SEVEN SCR ONE FIFTEEN MADAM
SECRETARY OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BURKE.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN.
THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO AND THEN.
FINAL AT SEA A ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR OF FIVE EXCUSE ME S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY SENATOR ROTH
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE. MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ.
IT'S VERY AN AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN.
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO AND THEN
FINALLY I THINK EVERYONE WAS
HERE FOR US HERE WHEN TENANTS
SO.
WITH THAT.
I'M JUST THEIR.
WAIT FOR A COUPLE MINUTES BUT
THAT WE'VE RUN THROUGH
EVERYTHING NOW HOMES.
EVEN IF YOU VOTED ON EVERYTHING
HERE YOU'RE ON YOUR GOOD BUT YOU
MUST LOOK AROUND AND KEEP ME
COMPANY.
OKAY SO WILL LEVEL LIBERAL UP
UNTIL FOUR THIRTY.
THIS WEEK WE CAN'T AND SO.
SO WE WILL OAK WE WILL WILL
ADJOURN THE MEETING WILL KEEP
THE ROLL UP AND FOR.
FOR THE NEXT TEN MINUTES
THANK YOU